zdf heute live herzlich willkommen es
ist mal wieder soweit es gibt beratungen
von bund und ländern diese dauern noch
an und anders als vor zwei tagen werden
heute auch entscheidungen erwartet
erwartet werden nämlich auf verschärfte
maßnahmen dazu warten wir auf die
pressekonferenz der noch bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel und des künftigen
bundeskanzlers olaf scholz außerdem
sprechen wir mit einer ganzen reihe von
kundigen leuten einfach an der leiterin
unserer redaktion recht und justiz hier
bei uns im studio saar attacke herzlich
willkommen schön dass du bei uns bist
außerdem uns zugeschaltet aus berlin
unsere korrespondentin nicole diekmann
auch die sehen wir herzlich willkommen
nicole schön dass du bei uns da bist und
später in der sendung sprechen wir dann
auch noch mit dem virologen martin
stürmer erste frage an nicole diekmann
und ja stehen die zeichen auf eine
zügige einigung heute in berlin ja also
meine glaskugel habe ich auch zu hause
gelassen aber die indizien die wir haben
die sprechen auf jeden fall dafür da ist
zum einen die beschlussvorlage wir
kennen sie mittlerweile sie gehört ja
zum ritual dazu das ist also das papier
an dem entlang verhandelt wird und ein
indiz für uneinigkeit sind eckige
klammern und davon finden sich in diesem
papier relativ wenige das heißt da
werden heute nur noch wenige strittige
punkte abzuarbeiten sein wie zum
beispiel dürfen überhaupt noch zuschauer
ins fußballstadion oder nicht das
nächste indiz dafür dass es heute
schnell gehen könnte ist du hast es ja
gerade gesagt man hat sich vor zwei
tagen schon zusammengesetzt das war
keine wirkliche
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz es war aber
dieselbe besetzung und da hat man die
weichen für heute schon gestellt das
zeigt auch dass man heute tatsächlich
mit beschlüssen an die öffentlichkeit
treten will weil man weiß man muss der
öffentliche druck ist einfach da und das
dritte in dies ist die kriegen ja immer
hinweise auf pressekonferenzen und so
weiter die zeiten die sind nicht ganz
verbindlich aber die wir jetzt so
zugeschickt bekommen die lassen auf ein
frühes ende dieser
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hoffen
lassen es auch erahnen vielen dank für
den moment wir beobachten natürlich auch
das podium wir haben gerade schon ein
bisschen was gesehen also noch tut sich
da nichts wir sind natürlich dann sofort
und live drauf wenn es losgeht wir
sprechen gleich weiter wir wollen uns
aber vorher noch mal angucken dass der
handlungsbedarf offenbar doch recht
großes jetzt inzwischen die rufe nach
klaren leitlinien und auch nach
einheitlichkeit sie sind in den letzten
tagen wieder sehr laut geworden über die
beratungen heute berichtet heike slansky
bilder wie diese erreichen uns täglich
aus ganz deutschland schlange stehen für
den impfstoff der manchmal sogar gar
nicht vorrätig für alle ist die politik
verspricht nun bis weihnachten bis zu 30
millionen zu impfen ein ehrgeiziges ziel
ausserdem soll der bundestag zeitnah
über eine allgemeine impfpflicht
abstimmen und zum jetzigen zeitpunkt wo
wir die situation haben dass viele
menschen die gerne an der impfung hätten
große schwierigkeiten haben eine
ranzukommen zu einer impfpflicht zu
reden ich habe das gefühl das lenkt
ehrlich gesagt von den realen problemen
haben die wir gerade haben wir reden
jetzt von einer impfpflicht nicht von
einem impfzwang das heißt aber am ende
auch dass das bußgeld bewehrt ist dass
man strafen zahlen muss wenn man sich
nicht dran hält das kennen wir auch bei
anderen pflichten in unserem land zur
stunde verhandeln bund und länder im
kanzleramt über verschärfte maßnahmen
bundesweiter künftig incident unabhängig
gelten zweig für kinos theater
restaurants sport und einzelhandel
ausgenommen geschäfte des täglichen
bedarfs strengere kontakt beschränkungen
für ungeimpfte auch bei privaten
zusammenkünften außerdem sollen
großveranstaltungen deutlich
eingeschränkt werden eine obergrenze von
30 prozent der kapazität ist im gespräch
was tatsächlich wichtig ist es quasi ein
lockdown für ungeimpfte denn das ist die
große zahl an ungeimpften über 12
millionen erwachsene das ist das was
auch das gesundheitswesen vor einer
herausforderung stellt wir brauchen
klare bundeseinheitliche regeln und die
werden wir ja heute auch verschärfen und
das werden wir als bremen auch mit gehen
zum beispiel wenn zweig im einzelhandel
beschlossen wird ich habe aber auch
immer gesagt wir brauchen eine hotspot
strategie drastische maßnahmen die die
vierte welle brechen sollen deutschland
im zweiten corona herbst die politik im
dauer krisen modus
ja die politik im dauer krisen modus das
kann der politik natürlich nicht
gefallen nicole diekmann beobachtet die
politik für uns aus nächster nähe du
hast die letzten tage auch mitbekommen
wie groß ist der druck auf die
verantwortlichen da jetzt substanziell
was zu bewegen
riesig und er kommt aus
unterschiedlichen zeiten da sind zum
einen die zahlen da sind vor allem die
intensivmediziner die alarm schlagen und
das erst nicht nicht erst in den letzten
tagen die intensivstationen sind zu voll
wir sehen bilder die ich würde mal sagen
niemand sehen will nämlich
schwerstkranke menschen die in
flugzeugen durch die republik
transportiert werden müssen weil eben an
einem ort nicht mehr so für sie gesorgt
werden kann wie das eigentlich müsste
und ein weiterer grund warum der druck
sich erhöht hat ist wir haben das ja
eben auch schon gesagt die öffentliche
meinung es sind die kritik ist zu laut
geworden sowohl an der noch
geschäftsführenden gruppe als auch an
der ja wahrscheinlich ab nächster woche
in amt und würden sein denn ampel dass
jetzt endlich etwas getan werden müsse
machtvakuum hin oder her das heißt also
man weiß ganz genau es ist jetzt
allerhöchste eisenbahn man muss jetzt
wirklich gas geben und schärfere
beschlüsse schaffen dankeschön nicole
ich lese gerade mal ein paar kommentare
vor die uns auch erreicht haben wir
lesen über youtube schreibt bitte einen
lock down entlastet die medizinischen
kollegen restaurants nur noch 2 g plus
also mit dann noch einem test
zusätzliche jan über youtube kein lockt
auch ein bitte also die meinungen gehen
auseinander vielleicht schaffen wir es
mit viel disziplin und impfen der lage
herr zu werden bei uns im studio ist
auch sarah attacke wie gesagt
redaktionsleiterin recht und justiz wenn
man das jetzt rechtlich betrachtet was
da heute so geplant ist wie kompliziert
ist das braucht es dann ein neues gesetz
oder befindet sich das alles noch
sozusagen im rahmen der bestehenden
möglichkeiten also die meisten maßnahmen
die da geplant sind nämlich schlecht
entdecken zweig auf den einzelhandel das
ist alles nach aktueller rechtslage
möglich da ist es nur so dass sie sich
in einer vereinbarung treffen wollen die
sich rechtsverbindlich aber wenn alle
länder gemeinsam beschließen wir machen
das so dann im besten fall auch so dass
sie erst auch so machen und der zweite
große punkt auch da braucht es jetzt
keine gesetzes nachschärfung ist dass
man sich darum kümmern will dass das was
man an ort und auch durchgesetzt wird
also dass man wirklich auch im ausweise
kontrolliert dass man zwei g2 gibt es
wirklich auch kontrolliert also um die
kontrollen geht es ganz stark da braucht
es aber auch keine gesetzesänderung
wofür ein neues gesetz bräuchten ist
eine impfpflicht das kann man nicht
einfach so beschließen da braucht es ein
gesetz her muss der bundestag
zusammentreten das heißt das kann man
jetzt heute nicht einfach so mit
beschließt man kann nur beschließt man
will das machen aber es muss dann noch
mal ein ordentliches gesetz geben und
was hier in dem in der beschlussvorlage
auch an klingt ist der plan dass man
doch gerne die möglichkeit wieder hätte
restaurants zu schließen das ist nach
aktueller rechtslage nicht möglich das
heißt da müsste man dann doch das
infektionsschutzgesetz dass man gerade
geändert hat wieder ändern isegrim
rookie beschreibt uns über youtube für
die impfpflicht spricht dass unsere
mitbürger endlich wieder ihren
geschäften nachgehen können sollten wir
können nicht unser gesundheitssystem und
die wirtschaft gegen die wand fahren so
ihre einschätzung über die empfiehlt
hamann gerade schon so ein bisschen
gesprochen wird es so du hast ja beim
letzten mal schon gesagt also du warst
ja auch der meinung dass die notbremse
dass man das ausgesetzt hat oder den
andersrum gesagt die epidemische notlage
ausgesetzt hat ein politischer fehler
war wird es jetzt auf die impfpflicht
hinauslaufen seiner einschätzung nach
zusammenhängen das schwierige ist
ehrlich gesagt und das sieht man an
deiner frage schon dass man überhaupt
noch über blickt was eigentlich gerade
gilt wir hatten vor zwei tagen die
entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts zur notbremse
die wiederum datiert aus dem april
diesen jahres ist im sommer ausgelaufen
war das einzige bundeseinheitlich
gesetzes wir hatten das gilt aktuell
nicht dann haben wir aber die
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite aus lauf lassen das nicht wir
sondern der bundestag hat das getan
stattdessen neue regelungen
infektionsschutzgesetz geschaffen die
jetzt wiederum geändert werden soll weil
man merkt gereicht doch nicht aus diese
änderung und das auslaufen der
epidemischen lage nationaler tragweite
war völlig unnötig und stiftet
verwirrung und das große problem ist
nicht dass man das jetzt hier richtig
sortiert hat sondern das problem ist
dass menschen die nicht juristen sind
und sich um die haupt profit damit
befassen ganz leicht den überblick
verlieren etwas ganz anderes ist es was
wir diskutieren ist die allgemeine
impfpflicht die gab es noch nicht wieder
für berufs also büros spezifisch noch
allgemein da braucht es ein gesetz das
das das muss neu geregelt werden dass
immer wieder komplett unabhängig von den
ganzen maßnahmen die im
infektionsschutzgesetz sind also das
wäre dann noch mal ein ganz anderes
gesetz völlig anders ja ist doch gut
dass wir das klären soll und gut dass
wir eine fachfrau da haben die das alles
auch noch mal einsortiert in der tat
manchmal schwierig den überblick zu
behalten wir wollen die runde erweitern
um martin stürmer wenn der uns auch
zugeschaltet ist da fahre ich gerade
nochmal nach doch da sehe ich im halo
herzlich willkommen virologe allseits
beliebter gast unserer sendung schon oft
dabei gewesen
herr stürmer wir haben es gerade eben
beitrag gehört es sieht aus nach einem
lock down für ungeimpfte mit den
maßnahmen die jetzt so beschlossen
werden die kommen sollen die auch die
länder jetzt teilweise schon machen
können ist das sozusagen das probate
mittel der wahl
es ist auf jeden fall ein schritt in die
richtige richtung ich meine es ist
natürlich nicht zu leugnen und und
abzustreiten das ist das gros der
infizierten menschen die jetzt auch
intensivstationen sind ungeimpfte sind
aber mir geht das in der jetzigen
situation nicht weit genug der grund ist
primär dass die zahlen insgesamt sehr
hoch sind und wir damit weiterhin auch
ein risiko dames durchbrüche in kauf
nehmen unabhängig von der neuen variante
omikron zu der ich gleichkomme und wenn
wir die zahlen nicht unterkriegen und
mit dem booster nicht gas geben dann
werden wir eben halt auch bei 2g die
probleme der übertragung sehen und
omikron ist ja noch ein unbekannter
spieler wo wir noch nicht genau wissen
wie es mit der verbreitung weitergeht
wie es mit dem impfstatus mit der winter
qualität der impfung mit der wirksamkeit
der impfung bestellt ist und wie sollte
ich das nicht weiß wäre ich jetzt dafür
für eine kurze zeit tatsächlich mal weg
zu gehen von sich geben wird um geimpft
und konsequent für alle die kontakte
soweit beschränken wie es geht
daneben sukzessive wieder aufmachen das
wäre meine bitte meine forderung also
der londoner im prinzip jetzt erstmal
für doch dann mehr oder weniger alle
wenn ich sie richtig verstehe auch für
die geimpften
ja so dass bis wir klarheit haben wie es
mit micon weiter geht es die zahlen
deutlich nach unten gehen wäre ich
tatsächlich für eine kurze zeit dafür
ich weiß ich bin selber geben ich würde
es selber beschneiden aber ich halte
dass es zum jetzigen zeitpunkt einfach
für notwendig weil es momentan ein thema
ist was auch im netz viele beschäftigt
es gibt videos die wir angehen teilweise
wo sich bitter beschwert wird auch von
krankenstationen beziehungsweise
pflegestationen oder auch eben aus
krankenhäusern sagen wir es mal so dass
die impfpflicht total unfair wäre und
dass es vor allem unfair ist dass
mitarbeiter ihre tests auch selber
bezahlen müssten vor allem in verbindung
eben auch nochmal mit der kritik an der
impfpflicht und daran dass der impfstoff
doch eventuell blutungen oder entweder
also auf jeden fall negative
auswirkungen haben könnte was sagen sie
dazu
also erstmal grundsätzlich ist die
impfung eigentlich der einzige weg
gewagt haben um aus diesem permanenten
kreislauf zwischen verschärfen der
maßnahmen und lockerung der maßnahme
rauszukommen jeder von denen die sich
beschweren möchte er wieder normales
leben haben inklusive der die sich jetzt
nicht so lauf beschweren aber wir wollen
ja alle wieder zurück zur normalität das
muss man einfach mal akzeptieren
respektieren dass die impfung
letztendlich der einzige weg ist und was
die sicherheit der impfstoffe angeht
unabhängig jetzt ob smm der vector
imstande sind wir haben milliardenfach
auf der welt bis jetzt gehen es gibt
meiner meinung nach kaum mehr daten zur
sicherheit von dem stoffen bietet diese
zur aktuellen zeit und da muss man
einfach mal ganz klar drauf gucken und
sich überlegen ob die ganze
argumentation
ich könnte ja vielleicht dies oder jenes
bekommen vielleicht doch nicht ganz so
zielführend ist
vielleicht hat er nochmal an der stelle
auch noch mal die frage an unsere
rechtsexperten wie ist das mit den im
test und auch mit den kosten generell
muss die schon der arbeitnehmer tragen
so ist es also es gilt aktuell wieder
dass mindestens ein test pro woche frei
ist vom bund übernommen wird aber
ansonsten ist es aktuell gesetzlich so
geregelt dass die arbeitnehmer selber
für die tests aufkommen müssen test auch
durchzuführen müssen die arbeitgeber
müssen zwar zwei tests die woche
anbieten die entsprechen aber nicht den
anforderungen die es braucht damit man
als ungeimpfter 3g am arbeitsplatz
erfüllen kann und wiederum die
testpflicht noch einmal enger ist auch
für alle die in der pflege arbeit oder
im krankenhaus aber oder auch als
besucher ins krankenhaus gehen oder in
altenheim gehen da gilt es egal ob
geimpfter ungeimpft jeder muss getestet
sein und an diese tests ist ein anderer
anspruch als müssen offizielle test sein
und keine selbstgemachte schnelltest
also man kann festhalten die
organisatorischen eventuell auch
finanziellen anforderungen könnten hoch
werden wenn man sich die ganze zeit
testen lassen muss klar es steht jedem
frei sich impfen zu lassen und wir haben
jetzt zumindest gerade noch mal von
herrn dr stürmer gehört dass die häufig
zumindest vorgetragenen argumente was
die gefährlichkeit eventuell des
impfstoffes angeht so offenbar mediziner
stand eben auch nicht zu halten sind
also das vielleicht noch mal zu diesem
themenkomplex ich würde sie gerne noch
mal fragen herr stürmer der stiko chef
mertens er hat gesagt in einem interview
stand heute würde er seine enkel nicht
impfen lassen er jetzt unabhängig davon
ob man diese äußerungen als politisch
klug oder nicht bezeichnen möchte können
sie denn inhaltlich dieser einschätzung
folgen
also er bezieht sich natürlich darauf
dass wir zwei sehr gute studiendaten
haben was die sicherheit angeht aber
eben bei einem relativ geringen
patientenkollektiv das ist jetzt so dass
natürlich in dem alter unter zwölf
jahren noch nicht so viele kinder
geimpft worden sind und die ständige
impfkommission prüft ja eben nicht nur
was zulassungsrelevante ist sondern eben
auch was darüber hinaus gehen an daten
aus der allgemeinbevölkerung eben in
anderen ländern zum beispiel an
erfahrung vorliegt und zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt haben wir auch noch nicht so
viele auf der anderen seite ist die
technik an sich ja durch eben die
massenhafte info bei den erwachsenen
doch als relativ sicher zu bewerten und
insofern würde ich eher dazu tendieren
die impfung auch für die unter
zwölfjährigen zu empfehlen einfach aus
dem grund unabhängig davon wie der
aktuelle verlauf bei kleinkindern ist er
ist harmlos da sind wir uns einig aber
wir wissen immer noch zu wenig und dann
muss mich erst mal jemand überzeugen mit
harten daten das longo wird bei kindern
keine rolle spielt und so lange ich das
nicht weiß möchte ich nicht sehen den
augen starr ein rennen einer ganzen
generation möglicherweise folgeschäden
angedeihen zu lassen denn wenn nicht
verständlich er verbringt man schreibt
lieber einheitliche maßnahmen kurz und
streng für alle als ewiges rauf und
runter mit den zahlen verbot bitte die
ganzen abgerissene hände belasten die
krankenhäuser ja das ist ja interessant
also auch da muss man vielleicht darauf
achten dass man jetzt als gesellschaft
eigentlich alles vermeiden sollte was
irgendwie dazu führt dass man ins
krankenhaus musste fiel jetzt eben frau
bringt man das bilderverbot 1 simon de
schreibt uns wir youtube zweig
ordentlich durchsetzen kurzer strenger
lockdown liebe grüße onkel kurt sagt er
ja weiß ich nicht genau wen er damit
meint ich lese einfach gerade noch mal
ein paar zuschriften vor miss
schwarzwaldmädel über youtube schulen zu
mir graut ist zwar für homeschooling
aber trotzdem vielleicht da gerade auch
noch mal die einschätzung des
medizinischen fachmanns schulen was ist
davon oder was ist da der aktuelle stand
sollte sollten also ich meine darüber
ist man sich eigentlich aus
gesellschaftlichen gründen offen bleiben
aber wie es medizinisch zu bewerten
wir haben natürlich in der altersklasse
die inzidenz bei den neuinfektionen
insofern ist das eine risikogruppe weil
auch eben die impfung für die zwölf- bis
18-jährigen noch nicht so lange auf dem
markt verfügbar ist und für die unter
zwölf noch gar nicht insofern oder jetzt
erst gerade kürzlich verfügbar ist
natürlich ein hohes risiko auf der
anderen seite sehen wir ihnen doch dass
die meisten infektionen von zu hause aus
der freizeit in die schulen rein
gebracht werden durch die stringente
testung denn doch auch erfasst werden
und so richtig komplexes
ausbruchsgeschehen in schulen und
kindergärten habe ich noch nicht
nachgewiesen worden ist insofern ist das
tatsächlich die letzte
letzte maßnahme die wir ergreifen
sollten wenn es gar nicht anders geht
und ich plädiere tatsächlich noch dafür
die schule und kindergärten so lange wie
es geht offen zu halten ja da ist mit
sicherheit wenig sozusagen gegenwind zu
erwarten also ich denke das ist die
meinung die uns auch die meisten
unserer userinnen und user so schicken
sarah vielleicht noch mal auch an dich
eben die frage jetzt aber gerade über
den schul lockdown gesprochen wie sieht
das aus generell mit den beschränkungen
oder das wird schon mal gesagt also wenn
jetzt weitere größere beschränkungen
kommen sollten die zumindest in der
alten im alten infektionsschutzgesetz
noch aufgelistet waren jetzt teilweise
eben nicht mehr da sind dann müsste es
ein neues infektionsschutzgesetz geben
für wie wahrscheinlich hältst du das
dieses kommt
eine gesetzesänderung und irgendwie hat
die politik das glaube ich auch schon
geahnt weil das gesetz wie es mal war
steht da noch man muss es nur wieder
aktivieren oder man kann auch einzelne
maßnahmen daraus aktivieren also was
aktuell gar nicht in debatte steht ist
flächendeckende schulschließung aber
auch die könnte man wieder aktivieren
und möglich machen will aktuell aber
keiner meines wissens dennoch steht eine
beschlussvorlage und das ist für mich
der springende punkt das doch geplant
ist eventuell wieder restaurant
schließung möglich zu machen dann müsste
man das gesetz noch mal anfassen und
wieder ändern ok also für den punkt
zumindest schon wir gucken gerade noch
mal nach berlin auf die pressekonferenz
sehen aber dass ich da noch nichts tut
und ich höre gerade auch dass ich das
wohl doch noch um einige minuten wenn
ich sogar um längere zeit verschiebt ich
will noch mal nachfragen bei nicole
diekmann falls jetzt da die möglichkeit
an und zwar ist man muss immer
vorsichtig sein diese technischen
möglichkeiten
genau nicht leute ankündigen die dann
nicht da ich gelernt ich nicht ein
gewisser und wir sehen dich auch also
was sind deine informationen wird es
noch etwas dauern ja als wäre dieser tag
die schon spannend genug in die aussagen
die jetzt sehen wir mehr ankommen
widersprechen einander ein bisschen auf
der einen seite heißt es kann noch bis
zu einer stunde dauern vielleicht sogar
länger jetzt lese ich hier gerade von
einer anderen quelle man sei beim
letzten punkt dieser beschlussvorlage
die uns hier vorliegt anhand derer man
sich entlang handelt also nichts genaues
weiß man nicht vielleicht ein trösten
eine tröstende information an diesem tag
für uns alle ist es gibt quasi eine
natürliche grenze für diese
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz heute abend
ist ja zapfenstreich für die caritas
oder bestimmt nicht versucht den
übertragen wie hier live im zdf auch
also auch allein deswegen musste sie
pünktlich da sein es geht so kurz nach
19 uhr los und darauf können wir uns
also verlassen bis dahin wird man
dadurch sein
das immer so schön in die kamera als wir
haben das auch hier ja diese
beschlussvorlage wahrscheinlich ist eine
noch ein bisschen duell als unsere in
den kopf genau also bei mir der letzte
punkt wäre jetzt das wissenschaftliche
experten gremium wird denn darüber dann
noch gestritten oder wie muss ich mir
das jetzt vorstellen oder hast du da
andere informationen
wir sind ja
technisch gesehen vortag gehören frau
dieckmann oder nicht da sehen wir jetzt
auch wieder frau dieckmann ich suche und
das hattest du mich gefragt hat doch ok
alles klar gut
ich habe tatsächlich anscheinend eine
frischere buchverlage als ihr da geht es
in meiner punkt 19 da geht es um
überbrückungshilfen und da ist
tatsächlich ich habe das ja eben schon
einmal gesagt diese eckigen klammern
eckige klammern zeigen immer dieser
punkt ist im vorfeld noch nicht
abgeräumt worden das heißt da muss man
doch mal tiefer in die diskussion gehen
in der konferenz selber und über die
überbrückungshilfen ist man sich im
grundsatz wohl eigentlich da geht es
aber anscheinend ich kann immer nur
sagen was mir eine quelle sagt das ist
noch nicht komplett gesichert wir setzen
hier aus zwei quellen prinzip aber in
der livesendung gebe ich das gerne
weiter es heißt jetzt mann sei noch am
letzten punkt und das sind eben die
überbrückungshilfen anscheinend verliert
man sich da gerade noch in den details
ich verstehe ja gut es geht ums geld
offenbar und da muss man dann immer ein
bisschen genauer hingucken vielen dank
nicole für den moment wir warten wie
gesagt alle auf die neuesten äußerungen
aus berlin aber noch ist es nicht der
fall und wir sprechen noch mal
beziehungsweise eine zuschrift
vielleicht gehabt noch an der stelle was
ist mit leuten die sich aus
gesundheitlichen gründen nicht impfen
lassen können denkt die politik auch an
die die werden mit maßnahmen ohne grund
gestraft ist das so richtig also wenn
man aus gesundheitlichen gründen sich
nicht impfen lassen kann dann muss es
doch da eigentlich ausnahmeregelungen
geben so ist es und die gibt es ja genau
also das ist so denke ich können wir das
nicht stehen lassen ich glaube da ist
die einschätzung falsch es ist auch von
einer impfpflicht ab 12 die rede markus
söder ist da vorgeprescht was ist davon
zu halten zum einen vielleicht mal auch
rechtlich erst ist das ohne weiteres
denkbar
also nicht ohne weiteres nicht also um
pflicht in der allgemeine oder auch eine
berufsspezifische und gerade eine für
minderjährige ist immer in jedem fall
ein erheblicher eingriff in die
grundrechte namentlich artikel 2
körperliche unversehrtheit
aber wenn man es mal einfach durch prüft
also was die politik im vorfeld macht
wenn sie gesetze er das und hinterher
richter machen um zu überprüfen ob diese
gesetze dann auch verhältnismäßig sind
eine impfpflicht auch für minderjährige
zum zweck beispielsweise um eine fünfte
welle zu verhindern müssen legitimes
ziel ja dann schaut man sich dann ist
das ganze auch geeignet und klar die
impfung schützt auch kinder sehr sehr
gut gegen das virus wir haben keinen
hundertprozentigen schutz und auch
keinen schutz der vermutlich über ein
halbes jahr so steckten kenntnisstand
meines wissens aktuell hinausgeht aber
für diesen zeitraum immerhin schützt der
impfstoff sehr sehr gut das heißt das
ganze ist auch geeignet wenn denn kinder
mit umfasst werden um eine fünfte welle
zu verhindern dann fragt man sich es
erforderlich und an diesem punkt schauen
gibt es nicht ein milderes mittel also
etwas was man machen kann um und klar
dass gibt es zum beispiel weniger
schweren eingriff in ihr dass das gleich
effektiv ist das ist ganz wichtig aber
wo der awo der eingriff nicht so schwer
ist das nicht so ein dass intensiv ist
man natürlich eine impfpflicht für
kinder sehr sehr eingriffs intensiv ist
und da könnte man sagen na ja wenn wir
jetzt erstmal alle maßnahmen ergreifen
b2g und die kontrollierende durchsetzen
und wenn wir gleichzeitig erstmals schon
mal eine impfpflicht 1 führen für
berufsspezifisch für pflegepersonal und
medizinisches personal
dann könnt ihr das doch schon ausreichen
und ist vielleicht auch ein gleich
effektives mittel frage zeichnet er
nicht war natürlich ist es umso
effektiver je mehr menschen geimpft
haben wir auch gelernt und während wir
von einem jahr noch davon ausgegangen
sind dass 70 prozent der bevölkerung
wenn die geimpft sind wir schon an ihren
der herdenimmunität haben wissen wir
jetzt dass es nicht der fall das heißt
vermutlich gibt es kein genauso
effektives aber milderes mittel und dann
sind wir schon bei der
verhältnismäßigkeit im engeren sinne und
da muss man ja auch ins feld führen dass
gerade vom bundesverfassungsgericht noch
mal anerkannte recht von kindern und
jugendlichen auf bildung das verletzt
und dagegen steht weil kindern soll es
weiterhin ermöglicht werden in die
schule zu gehen und
und und dass das spielte auch mit run
außerdem zwar sind kinder nicht nicht
der treiber der pandemie aber dennoch
können sich kinder infizieren und auch
andere infizieren auch das ist klar
belegt der stirn hatte gerade die zahlen
noch mal genannt das heißt wenn man das
hier gegeneinander abwägt also die
körperliche unversehrtheit den extrem
hohes schutzgut ist aber auf der
gleichen seite auch dagegen hält die
körperliche unversehrtheit von allen
anderen die durch bewohner infiziert
erkranken und auch sterben können das
recht auf bildung für die kinder das
auch beeinträchtigt sein kann dann gehe
ich davon aus und auch die entscheidung
des bundesverfassungsgerichts die wir
gerade hat mich nochmal gesagt hat die
politik hat einen enorm großen
entscheidungsspielraum dann würde ich
sagen auch eine impfpflicht für kinder
ist möglich aber entscheidend ist immer
was es stand der wissenschaft dazu
werden die politiker fragen und das
werden die gerichte fragen des weges
entscheidet was besser schlimmer sagt
wie wie gut dieser impfstoff für kinder
wirkt und auch wie hoch die risiken sind
ich bin mir sicher habt eine ausführung
mit interesse
er ist uns ja nach wie vor zugeschaltet
der doktor stimme was sagen sie dazu im
pflicht auch für jüngere menschen sprich
ab 12
es ist insgesamt ein sehr schwieriges
thema das ist dass die impfpflicht ich
bin da so ein bisschen hin- und
hergerissen ich denke wenn wir die
impfung für alle haben und ins nächste
jahr mal rüber schauen und
wahrscheinlich nach der neben den
fülligen den sommer gehen wieder mit
deutlich geringeren zahlen arbeiten
werden kann es durchaus sein dass wir da
gar nicht mehr darüber diskutieren
müssen weil wir irgendwann auch zur
normalität zurück wir haben viele
infektionskrankheiten die wir bekämpfen
können über keine impfpflicht haben und
auch keine brauchen wir müssen schauen
wo das ganze in die kurzfristig denke
ich mache das sind je mehr geimpft sind
umso besser was die jugendlichen angeht
die wirkung der impfstoffe die steht
außerhalb der debatte das haben studien
gezeigt egal in welcher altersgruppe
hocheffektiv neben dem schweren verlauf
und und die krankheit und die weitergabe
des virus zu verhindern
auf der anderen seite wissen wir noch
etwas zu wenig über die möglichen
nebenwirkungen in der breite gerade bei
den fünf- bis zwölfjährigen um das
abschließend bewerten zu können ich gehe
aber davon aus dass wir da keine
übermäßig starken signale in richtung
neuer nebenwirkungen bekommen werden
weil es ginge nur also in der debatte
steht ja nur eine impfpflicht ab 12 also
nicht für die ganz kleinen ab 12 es ist
da denn wie es da der kenntnisstand ist
das ist die impfung für kinder ab zwölf
gefährlicher gibst oder gibt es dann
auch eine geringere datenlager als bei
kind also menschen ab 18 also vorherigen
ja die datenlage ist natürlich geringer
für die 12 bis 16 bis 17 jährigen auf
der anderen seite haben wir da ja auch
schon die die empfehlung der ständigen
impfkommission und insofern ist das
zumindest in der form abgeprüft dass
dort auch die kolleginnen und kollegen
sagen wir haben genug evidenz dafür dass
eben die die an nutzen die risiken eben
bei weitem über übertreffen und insofern
denke ich dass da die datenlage
ausreichend an de polo schreibt uns über
facebook 70 prozent der deutschen
bevölkerung ist geimpft und 30%
ungeimpfte sollen schuld an all dem sein
was gerade abgeht ich würde es nicht
gleich ja sagen im prinzip läuft ein
bisschen darauf hinaus oder wie sehen
sie das
das gros sicherlich ja das gros der
infizierten sind ungeimpfte aber wir
haben eben die hilft durchbrüche die
mitte handeln müssen und wir haben eben
omikron als neun spieler und das kann es
passieren dass mit der nikon variante
geben noch mehr im durchbrüche sehen
werden insofern ist es nicht ganz
korrekt ist nur auch die ungeimpften
abzuschieben eine pandemie die
umkämpften es an bord was mehr in der
form nicht so gut gefällt ja okay gut
dass ich das auch noch mal klar gestellt
haben aber vielleicht gerade noch mal zu
den impf durchbrüchen dass man jetzt
also hört dass es auf den
intensivstationen auch öfter dazu kommt
dass dort leute liegen die geimpft sind
oder zumindest mal auch im krankenhaus
ankommen das ist doch statistisch
gesehen wenn immer mehr leute geimpft
sind eigentlich erstmal nicht
ungewöhnlich
nein das ist zum einen nicht
ungewöhnlich und das ist auch ein
phänomen was wir ja mehr oder weniger
erwartet haben wir wussten noch nicht
genau zu welchem zeitpunkt das passiert
die meisten impfungen wenn man sie mit
einer besagen sogenannten
grundimmunisierung startet also zweimal
macht von drei oder vier wochen halten
nicht lebenslänglich und das war von
vornherein klar dass wir irgendwann
nachrüsten müssen und wir haben jetzt
gesehen dass der zeitpunkt ebenso
zwischen fünf und sechs monaten liegt
auch in der allgemeinbevölkerung
und das ist jetzt so wichtig
entsprechend nach zu impfen wenn wir das
konsequent tun werden wir auch wieder
weniger in durchbrüche sehen und auch
entsprechend weniger menschen mit dem
springen auf der intensivstation
hersteller black star fragt uns über
youtube warum sind geimpfte von der test
pflicht befreit wenn doch geimpfte sich
ebenfalls infizieren können und das
virus weiter geben können das ergibt
keinen sinn
das ist korrekt und jetzt im zeitpunkt
macht es durchaus sinn auch geimpfte und
genießen mit in einer test strategien zu
nehmen also zweig plus sozusagen zu
machen und gerade in wohl allen
bereichen wäre das sicherlich adäquat
das problem ist die pcr test kapazität
in unserem lande sind absolut erschöpft
wäre dann kaum noch möglichkeiten den
laboren unsere befunde zeit heraus zu
geben was wir möchten und müssen und der
anti gen test hat gerade bei den
entsprechenden doch eher ein paar
schwächen dass da eben nicht unbedingt
der auch anschlägt wenn jemand der den
durchbruch hat insofern bin ich ja eben
einfach aufgrund dieser ganzen situation
eben dafür jetzt vor ein paar wochen
keine unterschiede zu machen aber
grundsätzlich ist die frage absolut
berechtigt
was ich vorhin schon gegeben haben dass
sie gesagt haben naja also für eine
kurze zeit zumindest wäre es sinnvoll
wenn es quasi eine art lok tor und für
alle geben würde andere christ fragt uns
wofür schützt die impfung kinder fieber
kinder überstehen eine kur oder
infektion zu wie viel prozent
unbeschadet also vielleicht noch mal ja
auch da noch die frage hinten dran wie
schwer ist der verlauf für kinder in der
regel in der regel ist der verlauf der
gute verlauf für die kinder absolut
harmlos das ist auch gar keine gar nicht
in der diskussion da sind uns alle einig
je jünger die kinder sind umso besser
verkraften sie die aktuelle die akute
infektion mehr geht es in der diskussion
darum dass zum einen trotzdem infizierte
kinder andere anstecken können und
selbst wenn das sehr unwahrscheinlich es
kann ja auch mal ein kind einen schweren
verlauf haben das gilt es zu vermeiden
gehen da können auch erwachsene
anstecken die vielleicht dann eben
entsprechend schwer verläufe haben und
wir wissen zu wenig noch über longo mit
dh ich weiß überhaupt nicht was
möglicherweise an folgeschäden aus
dieser infektion wenn sie harmlos
verläuft bleiben kann ich bin jetzt kein
kind mehr aber ich habe einen harmlosen
verlauf letztes jahr im märz gehabt mit
dieser infektion ich habe immer noch
beeinträchtigungen weil gewohnt
geschmack damit kann ich gut leben aber
ich weiß dass nämlich das virus zum
beispiel verändert hat wenn ich möchte
nicht dass er das bei unseren kindern
und jugendlichen auch in kauf nehmen big
ed fragt uns über youtube das ist
vielleicht eine frage die man sowohl
medizinisch als auch rechtlich
diskutieren könnte warum ist es
eigentlich nicht möglich nicht geimpfte
menschen einfach nicht zu behandeln und
könnte das nicht sozusagen eine
impfpflicht beinhalten na ja gut es ist
wahrscheinlich mit einem ärztlichen
schwer zu vereinbaren zum einen
das ist genau wie die diskussion wenn
ich jetzt zur trias komme oder das war
ja die frage im hintergrund auch wenn
ich in die kirche gehe das wird ein
medizinischer aspekte und da geht es
nicht darum wer hat wie viel geld wer
hat sich gm verhält sich nicht geimpft
das ist unethisch und sicherlich keine
maßnahmen über die man länger
diskutieren sollte sondern dass da
eigentlich in der diskussion in der
formel 1 nichts zu suchen sagt du hast
auch direkt bedruckt und
absolut abhängig also
es gibt ja wenig dinge die absolut sind
aber da kann man absolut sagen undenkbar
und denkbar weil sie gerade das wort
rage angesprochen haben herr doktor
stürmer wie sehen sie da die gefahr wir
haben aus österreich die meldung
bekommen gestern auch heute wieder das
dort teilweise schon so eine art ria
stattfindet aus deutschland gab es so
diese meldung direkt noch nicht aber die
warnung natürlich dafür dass das auch
kommen könnte wie sehen sie die
entwicklung
wir fangen ja schon an menschen quer
durch die republik zu transportieren die
eigentlich nicht transportiert werden
sollten weil sie eben schwerst krank
sind und eigentlich alle notwendige
pflege vor ort brauchen und das ist ja
schon mal ein schritt dorthin dass wir
eben die überlastung sehen man versucht
das noch zu kompensieren und schafft das
auch noch aber wir haben heute ja auch
wieder auch wenn wir uns so ein bisschen
auf einem plateau bewegen über 70.000
neue infizierte und in anderthalb zwei
wochen landen die auch zum hof zu einem
gewissen anteil auf den
intensivstationen und auf der anderen
seite gehen aber auch nicht viele vor
den intensivstationen so schnell wieder
runter wie patienten ein bisschen länger
liegen also wir müssen ganz ganz gehörig
aufpassen dass uns das in den nächsten
wochen nicht um die ohren fliegt
das dürfte so sagen vielen dank für
diese einschätzung ich gucke gerade mal
ob wir noch ein paar zuschriften haben
denn wir haben immer noch ein bisschen
zeit wir gucken ab und so auf die
räumlichkeiten in berlin und sehen dass
da aber noch nichts passiert ist was das
podium angeht l 7 as schreibt uns über
youtube macht einfach zweige plus für
den gesamten freizeitbereich 3g für
lebensnotwendiges und zweig für den rest
dann steigt die impfquote von alleine
und das infektionsgeschehen wird
nachvollziehbarer und über youtube
erreicht uns noch eine zukunft wenn eine
impfpflicht muss diese gezielt
ausgesprochen werden sprich die
variablen gruppen ist das denn ohne
weiteres möglich kann man da also was
die impfpflicht angeht die bevölkerung
teilen in bestimmte gruppen oder ist das
dann auch wieder das würde geben ganz
klar also deswegen das ist ja auch das
was es wäre sogar ehrlich gesagt
vermutlich das mildeste mittel zu sagen
wir machen erstmal eine impfpflicht nur
für eine spezifische gruppe wie
beispielsweise medizinisches und
pflegepersonal also die eben in kontakt
mit menschen die durch eine infektion
sehr wahrscheinlich sterben und und da
gibt es natürlich auch noch mal also ist
das ist das ist das schutzgut zwar immer
noch die körperliche unversehrtheit
derjenigen personen geimpft aber dagegen
liegt die besondere gefahr dass diese
person wenn sie ungeimpft ist ungleich
höher jemanden infizieren kann er dann
auch schweren verlauf hat und am ende
auch sterben kann das heißt bevor man im
pflicht für alle macht wäre eine
berufsspezifische impfpflicht natürlich
milderes mittel
durchaus denkbar möglich und machbar
eine impfpflicht für alle ab 18 wäre das
andere auch die ist machbar jetzt aus
juristischer sicht je nachdem wie sie
ausgestaltet ist und dann gibt es
natürlich noch die möglichkeit das ganze
zu erwarten und sagen es ist eine
allgemeine impfpflicht die schon ab 12
jahren greift auch das ist je nach
ausgestaltung machbar juristisch gesehen
verstehe jetzt haben wir gerade hier
oder sehen immer noch eine dame die dort
offenbar etwas vorbereitet wir wissen
jetzt nicht genau ob das jetzt glaube
ich irgendwelche mappen und stifte
verteilt ob das jetzt darauf hindeutet
dass es in wenigen augenblicken losgeht
befürchten das ist immer noch ein wenig
dauern könnte vielleicht auch noch mal
ja vielleicht auch noch mal die frage an
die kopier dieses zeremoniell da
vertraut ist und ob das jetzt darauf
hindeutet das ist vielleicht dann doch
geht es in wenigen augenblicken losgehen
könnte oder gibt es da noch nichts neues
aus berlin
so aus berlin gibt es jetzt auch wieder
ein bild im moment ist tatsächlich aber
nichts neues und ich würde mich jetzt
auch erstmal zurückhaltend mit prognosen
denn bisher waren die alle falsch aber
also die natürliche grenze heute abend
ist
kurzen streich für angela merkel darauf
können wir uns alle verlassen ja
vielleicht gerade noch mal die
politische einordnung des tages nochmal
auch die frage an dich nicole also die
ampel parteien irgendwie hatte man den
eindruck der staat war jetzt nicht so
optimal auch olaf scholz da hatten sich
viele erhofft dass er doch da klarere
ansagen machen würde das ist jetzt in
den letzten tagen so ein bisschen mehr
gekommen aber ich glaube da hat es für
noch schon angedeutet da wird immer noch
einiges jetzt erwartet und da muss noch
geliefert werden ja also um das nochmal
ganz korrekt darzustellen noch regiert
die ampel ja nicht also der staat der
offizielle start soll nächste woche sein
wir erinnern uns nikolaus ist coco aus
nächste woche ist nikolaus da soll dann
olaf scholz vereidigt werden dann
erfahren wir vielleicht auch endlich wer
eigentlich gesundheitsminister werden
soll oder gesundheitsministerin wir
wissen ja bisher nur er oder sie soll
aus den reihen der spd kommen ansonsten
hält man sich da noch sehr bedeckt die
ampel ist aber natürlich schon in der
verantwortung auch wenn sie noch nicht
in der regierung ist genauso aber auch
wie die geschäftsführende
bundesregierung das ist ja der große wie
soll ich da sagen das ist ja der punkt
um den herum sich der unmut der
öffentliche unmut entzündet dass man
also sagt uns ist völlig egal ob jetzt
die geschäftsführende groko noch was
beschließen muss oder ob die demnächst
regierende ampel etwas beschließen kann
setzt euch jetzt endlich alle an einen
tisch und beschließt irgendetwas und das
wird halt von heute von dem heutigen tag
erwartet
kritik war zu laut und man sieht jetzt
auch diese kritik fruchtet wer die
vergangenen tage beobachtet hat
entschuldigung olaf scholz war
vorgestern bei bild tv anschließend war
er bei uns im zdf im heute journal hat
sich da den fragen von marietta slomka
gestein ist war christian sievers
gestellt die beiden werden oft
miteinander verwechselt gestern bei joko
und klaas und heute ein großes interview
in der zeit also er kommt jetzt auch in
die offensive in die
kommunikationsoffensive und das hat
diese pandemie ja auch gezeigt wie
wichtig kommunikation ist
absolut und neben dem zettel und den
stiften wird jetzt auch noch wasser
verteilt also wir klammern uns hier an
jeden strohhalm jetzt muss es wirklich
bald los wir sind ja sehr vorgenommen
nicole dass dubai und frisst und mit uns
das alles noch mal so ein bisschen schon
im vorfeld auch beleuchtet ist ja da hat
es gerade angesprochen das amt des
bundesgesundheitsministers da hört man
unterschiedliches das ist ja interessant
da gab es noch richtige petitionen
sozusagen oder zumindest große
bewegungen die karl lauterbach fordern
was ist da zu hören ist das
wahrscheinlich ist es eher
unwahrscheinlich
was ja eine riesige besonderheit der
vergangenen wochen ist in denen erst
sondierungs- und dann
koalitionsgespräche liefen war diese
verschwiegenheit was wir als
journalisten natürlich total genervt zur
kenntnis genommen haben wir leben von
informationen herausgegeben haben was
aber natürlich auch für eine gewisse
disziplin in dieser kommenden ampel
koalition spricht was ja nicht schadet
das geht jetzt weiter also es ist auch
in dieser personalie bisher sehr wenig
nach außen gedrungen dass es gerade
schon gesagt es gab eine große welle
auch in den sozialen netzwerken wählt
karl war der hashtag karl lauterbach der
sich ja in den vergangenen monaten in
sehr vielen talkshows in vielen tönen in
vielen interviews geäußert hat
fachkundig zur pandemie er ist ja
mediziner den wollen viele als
bundesgesundheitsminister aber es wäre
jetzt das erste mal würde mich sehr
erstaunt dass die sozialen netzwerke
teil daran haben wer in einer
bundesregierung welchen posten bekommt
spaß beiseite was wir hören ist es gibt
bedenken in der spd vor allem von seiten
von olaf scholz
lauterbach und er gelten nicht gerade
als enge freunde und
deswegen gibt es auch einen anderen
namen der im moment hier die runde macht
das ist der von peter tschentscher das
ist der regierende bürgermeister der
erste bürgermeister von hamburg
dessen namen macht hier eben name macht
hier auch gerade die runde aber auch das
wäre das wäre nicht das erste mal es
kann am ende dann doch jemand ganz
anderes werden
natürlich am ende konnte es nicht werden
aber wer schon mal interessant man
könnte den kreis so ein bisschen
einengen also aus der spd offenbar das
wird manchmal sagen aber in der tat ist
nein ja wir warten ab wir wollen
vielleicht das ganze noch mal kurz
unterbrechen wir warten wie gesagt immer
noch auf die protagonisten die aber noch
nicht zu sehen sind und wir wollen noch
mal einen beitrag zeigen dieser dauer
appell lassen sie sich impfen der ist
immer noch bei vielen menschen leider
auch nicht fruchtbaren boden gefallen in
der planung deshalb eine baldige
impfpflicht für bestimmte berufsgruppen
wir haben es ja auch bei uns jetzt
mehrfach an diskutiert vor allem eben in
pflegeeinrichtungen
doch einige personalverantwortliche
sehen diesen schritt auf wiederum eher
skeptisch die sorge ist groß dass dann
viele ungeimpfte pflegekräfte sagen
könnten okay das war's dann für mich und
nicht weiter machen wollen zu diesem
thema mehr von sibylle bassler
dem knall lotte jobst und ihr hausarzt
dr fleischhauer haben ihn noch nicht
gehört hier in jena winzerla für mehr
tempo beim impfen gehe es jetzt nicht
darum wer die spritze setzen darf
sondern womit problem ist der impfstoff
also wir haben zum beispiel bestellt und
kriegen von den bestellten mengen nur
etwa 60 prozent also von mir und auch
wenn das impfen plus sprechstunde im
pandemie modus anstrengend ist der
hausarzt ist skeptisch dass jetzt auch
apotheken die lizenz zum impfen bekommen
sollen es geht nicht nur darum das
handwerk zu machen die impfungen zu
verabreichen das können sie auch
jemanden beibringen der zwölf jahre alt
ist es gibt auch darum wenn ich die
impfung verabreicht habe was passiert
dann wenn möglicherweise eine
komplikation auftritt als der umgang
damit impfen sagt er ist deshalb aufgabe
von medizinischem personal per gesetz 30
millionen erst zweit und
auffrischungsimpfungen sind aber jetzt
als ziel gesetzt bis weihnachten kann
mit hilfe der apotheken der impf schnell
klappen
unrealistisch warnt die branche weil es
ist viel zu organisieren schulungen
räumlichkeiten und ich gehe davon aus
dass das wirklich bis ins erste quartal
20 22 zieht bis wir hier dann wissen
wieviel apotheken impfen werden jede
zehnte vielleicht nur jede zwanzigste
thüringer apotheker werde sich wohl
beteiligen
setzen sich noch einen kleinen moment
draußen hin frau yorks hausarzt
christian fleischauer würde seine
patienten gern wie versprochen pünktlich
booster
ab nächster woche muss er aber
vielleicht einige vertrösten weil ihm
dann das wichtigste fehlen könnte
ausreichend impfstoff
ist natürlich auch wichtig zum impfen
der impfstoff herr doktor stürmer wir
haben gerade gesehen also einige
probleme die da natürlich momentan
vorhanden sind das war übrigens ein
beitrag von mathias gubo zahlen nicht
von der geschützten frau basler aber
trotzdem kommen wir noch einmal auf
dieses problem zurück wie wichtig ist es
jetzt dass andere stellen wie zb
apotheken zahnärzte et cetera auch mit
impfen dürfen
ich würde jetzt nicht zu viel
durcheinander reinbringen wir haben ja
im prinzip der logistik etabliert gehabt
wir hatten die impfzentren dann sind die
haus und betriebsärzte mit drauf
gesprungen dann haben wir gesehen dass
die impfmüdigkeit der bevölkerung oder
das zdf eliten nachlässt die die wir
impfen wollten diese lassen wollten
hatten wir durch dame die impfzentren
stillgelegt und die hausärzte betriebsam
den rest wieder übernommen jetzt wieder
mehr da würde ich jetzt nicht wieder
neues fass aufmachen soll ich würde dir
impfzentren wieder reaktivieren und im
prinzip dort in der kombination mit den
außen betriebsärzten wieder gas geben
aha auch ein interessanter punkt also
lieber die alten strukturen beibehalten
gut okay ich nochmal die frage ich habe
sie zwar führen schon formuliert aber es
sind ja mit sicherheit auch noch einige
userin und user neu dazugekommen in der
zwischenzeit weil es eben doch hohe
wellen schlägt der stiko chef thomas
mertens er hatte gesagt er würde sein
siebenjähriges kind aktuell noch nicht
impfen lassen die datenlage für die
stiko wäre dazu noch nicht ausreichend
es gibt ja eben auch noch keine
offizielle empfehlung von der stiko
vielleicht nochmal ihre einschätzung
dazu bzw wie bewerten sie die arbeit der
der stiko allgemeinen da wird ja oft
kritisiert das würde zu lange dauern
können sie da vielleicht in die bresche
springen
ja es ist immer einen unterschied
zwischen den daten die zu einer
zulassung führen und der allgemeinen
bewertung für eine empfehlung die
ausgesprochen wird die stiko hat uns
lange lange jahre begleitet hat immer
wieder unsere impfempfehlungen
aktualisiert jetzt steht sie sehr im
fokus sehr in der kritik weil natürlich
die zeit hier in der wichtige rolle
spielt
neben dem fortschritt so weit wie
möglich nach zu beschleunigen dann auf
der anderen seite hat die stiko
natürlich eine gewisse
gewissen einfluss auch für die
entscheidung vieler ärztinnen und ärzte
und dem will sie natürlich auch gerecht
werden und prüft entsprechend sorgfältig
und das ist auch der vorwurf der oft
gemacht wird ihr habt das ganze zu
schnell auf den markt gebracht jetzt ist
hier eine eine institution die sich die
zeit nimmt die untersuchung sorgfältig
vorzunehmen dann ist es auch nicht
richtig also man muss schon wissen was
man will natürlich möchten wir alle
gerne möglichst schnell die impfung
haben damit es vorwärtsgeht ich denke
dass die impfung für den fünf- bis
zwölfjährige sicher genug sein wird dass
die bedenken eigentlich eher nicht
notwendig sein werden aber die stiko
prüft hat eben jetzt die daten die
vorliegen aus anderen ländern und was
ich gehört habe es zumindest eine
empfehlung noch in diesem jahr geben
dankeschön ja sie hatten gesagt dass man
noch zu wenig weiß über die
langzeitfolgen von kurve bei kindern was
weiß man denn also auch wenn es nur
wenig ist was weiß man zu langzeitfolgen
bei kindern also nach einer kuh mit
infizierung
es gibt gibt sehr viele unterschiedliche
aussagen dazu und dann zum
unterschiedlichem maße haben wir halt
eben diese ganzen
erschöpfungszustände diese diese
müdigkeit symptomatik wieder einhergeht
und glaube dass ist so mit dass das
hauptproblem es ist schwer zu greifen
was man wirklich und alkohol versteht
wir sind da sehr am anfang da ist die
begrifflichkeit noch nicht so eindeutig
definiert und das wegen sage ich das ist
ein noch sehr stiefmütterlich erforscht
bereich viele viele sachen die man dabei
beobachtet haben möglicherweise gar
nichts mit der infektion zu tun sondern
eher mit den umständen die mit einher
gehen mit unserer ganzen situation mit
homeschooling mit mit der distanzierung
von freunden und untermalt mögen auch
bestimmte symptome mit einhergehen des
weges ist aber ganz schwierig zu
differenzieren aber umso wichtiger wenn
man es noch nicht weiß das ist ja meine
argumentation wenn ich es nicht
eindeutig weiß dass es komplett
ungefährlich ist bin ich eher immer
derjenige der zur vorsicht mahnt diese
einschätzung herr doktor stimme wie
entlassen sie mal für ein paar minuten
wir sprechen später in der sendung dann
aber gerne weiter noch mal mit ihnen vor
allem dann natürlich wenn die beschlüsse
vorliegen da stehen sie uns dann noch
zur verfügung dankeschön für den moment
wir gucken bei dieser gelegenheit
nochmal nach berlin aber müssen leider
feststellen da also nicht leiter dass
sie verliebt war sehen an gottes werden
da bin ich sehr froh ich wollte nur
sagen dass da auf der pressekonferenz
noch nichts passiert nicole du bist bei
uns das ist wunderbar genau es gibt
offenbar immer noch den gesprächsbedarf
in berlin man tauscht sich noch aus über
detail probleme wir hatten film gehört
es geht wohl doch ums geld generell wie
würdest du das einschätzen wie ist da
jetzt die zusammenarbeit zwischen bund
und ländern klar geld fragen sind
wichtig aber auf der anderen seite es
ist irgendwie auch klar ist muss am ende
heute was rauskommen ja das ist ein klar
und in dieser beschlussvorlage
anhand derer von der rolle beschlüsse
fassen möchte ich würde fast sagen muss
wird auch klar dass viele punkte die ja
auch einigen diskussionsstoff in sich
bergen schon abgeräumt waren bevor man
sich da heute zusammen geschaltet hat es
ist ja eine weitestgehend digitale
konferenz eben wegen corona also zweig
in restaurants in im einzelhandel
abgesehen von läden die für den
täglichen bedarf zuständig sind zweig in
kultureinrichtungen das sind ja auch
schon eine harte beschränkungen die man
da heute beschließen will und noch mal
da gab es keine eckigen klammern das
heißt da war man sich eigentlich schon
einig dass man das heute auf den weg
bringt das ist ein deutliches zeichen
dafür dass man die marschroute gemeinsam
ein stück nämlich in richtung harte
maßnahmen man sieht die zahlen man sieht
man hört die rufe vor allem von
intensivmedizinern also es ist schwer
von hier jetzt aus zu sagen woran man
gerade noch sitzt warum man auch gerade
mal noch diskutiert das muss ja auch
kein schlechtes zeichen sein also ich
glaube nicht dass man da heute
zerstritten aus dieser runde heraus
kommen und sagen wird wir konnten uns
leider auch nichts einigen denn hinzu
kommt ja noch man hat ja auch vor zwei
tagen sie schon zusammen geschaltet um
quasi diese heute heutige
ministerpräsidenten konferenz
vorzubereiten eben weil man weiß man
muss geschlossenheit
handlungsfähigkeit und ergebnisse
präsentieren die erwartungshaltung der
öffentlichkeit ist da völlig klar
demnach hat es dich wahrscheinlich dann
auch nicht überrascht dass man sich so
gut geeinigt hat bzw dass die
vorbereitungen schon so weit
fortgeschritten waren auf den heutigen
tag vorgestern als man sich zum ersten
nicht zum ersten mal aber als man sich
das letzte mal jetzt eben vor heute
getroffen hat und das ganze vorbereitet
hat das tempo war dann offenbar schon
recht gut und die fortschritte eben auch
aus den genannten gründen genau und das
ging ja auch relativ schnell es hatten
ja unterschiedliche menschen
unterschiedliche wege zurückzulegen
inhaltlich eigentlich war ja diese
heutige mpk für kommende woche
donnerstag angesetzt für den neunten
dezember und dadurch dass man sich halt
auch schon vorgestern am 30 november
dann schon das erste mal zusammen
gesetzt hat war ja auch schon wiederum
klar wir haben verstanden wir hören die
signale wir müssen uns jetzt früher
zusammensetzen und warum sollte man sich
zusammensetzen auch zweimal innerhalb
derselben woche die beteiligten haben ja
auch noch andere sachen zu tun wenn man
nicht ganz klar wüsste und auch das
signal senden wollte wir müssen jetzt
was tun so kann es nicht weitergehen die
lage ist viel zu dramatisch
wir werden auch nochmal hier gefragt an
dieser stelle ich muss gerade noch mal
kurz hoch ist rollen robert schramm über
youtube woran liegt diese extreme impf
gegnerschaft zum beispiel sagt er in
sachsen aber es ist ja nicht nur in
sachsen der fall und wie sollte man
damit umgehen ich könnte mir vorstellen
dass das ja auch ein thema ist was in
der politik ja auch jetzt rauf und
runter besprochen wird wo die parteien
sicher dann auch fragen okay was haben
wir vielleicht in der kommunikation
falsch gemacht warum erreichen wir einen
so hohen anteil von leuten irgendwie
immer noch nicht gibt es da hörst du da
irgendwie selbstkritische erkenntnisse
zu aus der einen oder anderen partei
oder ist man da einfach steht man da von
einem rätsel
naja die gründe für die skepsis im
ablehnung die sind vielfältig das
versuchen wir medienschaffende ja auch
immer wieder aufzubereiten da gibt es
unterschiedliche annahmen
ich glaube definitiv sagen woran es
liegt kann man nicht weil weil es eben
viele unterschiedliche gründe gibt auf
der anderen seite du hast gerade nach
politischen aussagen gefragt ich
erinnere mich bei der letzten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz saß
anschließend
zusammen mit olaf scholz und angela
merkel auch berlins regierender
bürgermeister müller und der sagte
tatsächlich man habe vernünftig
kommuniziert an der politik liege es
nicht und nannte da unter anderem
bequemlichkeit als einen grund den er
als ein
anlass erachtet dafür für leute sich
nicht impfen zu lassen
ich glaube alles andere als die
impfpflicht feld der politik da im
moment auch kaum noch ein und eben immer
wieder appelle auch das steht ja in der
beschlussvorlage und zwar ganz ganz weit
oben lassen sie sich bitte impfen aber
das hören wir ja auch schon seit beginn
des jahres quasi das sogenannte
impfangebot
vielleicht auch das ein kommunikatives
problem wenn man sagt das ist ein
impfangebot dann wird das auch als ein
angebot aufgefasst von manchen leuten
die also sagen ich kann aber ich muss
nicht und dies dann eben auch nicht
machen das heißt also die impfpflicht
ist jetzt das womit man versucht aus
dieser misere die man sich zum teil eben
auch selbst geschaffen hat wieder
herauszukommen
so genau und und rechtlich muss man
sagen sind da jetzt viele maßnahmen
eingeführt worden die wahrscheinlich
auch nochmal bewegung ins impfen bringen
werden gerade drei geht am arbeitsplatz
also dass ich als ungeimpfter und
genießen da jeden tag ein test machen
muss um mich um ihn kümmern muss als
auch 3g in bus und bahn wird viele
bewegen die auf bus und bahn angewiesen
sind weil dieses täglich sich testen
müssen um zur arbeit zu können um bahn
fahren zu können oder aber auch zweig
für restaurants für geschäfte außer
supermärkte also dass man am normalen
leben nicht mehr teilnehmen kann ohne
aufwand oder auch und gar nicht mit 2g
heißt ja als ungeimpft dass man gar
nicht mit dabei das sind alles maßnahmen
die dazu führen werden dass es unbequem
wird ungeimpft zu sein und ich glaube
die gruppe der ideologische impfgegner
ist es das sind je in jedem fall nicht
die 20% oder 30% und nervten die wieder
haben besonders ein ganz großer teil
dieser indifferenz sind irgendwie mal
gucken wollten sich auch nicht die nicht
um mit den führenden wollten oft anders
zieht wie vor bayern uns nicht
ausreichend leute werden schon mitmachen
dann muss ich nicht und für die wird
jetzt unbequem
ungeimpft zu sein also und das wird
nochmal motivieren dass das auf der
einen seite und auf der anderen seite
könnte man ja auch sich vorstellen dass
so eine nebenpflicht auch psychologisch
einfach eine hilfe sein könnte weil dann
ist es eben eine pflicht und es wird von
mir als bürger erwartet dass sich dieser
pflicht nachkommen hilft vielleicht auch
so in der argumentation der eigenen
peergroup ein bisschen zu sagen ja aber
sorry jetzt ist es halt so wir sind alle
verpflichtet das zu machen und es ist
könnte ich mir vorstellen dann doch
vielleicht auch eine argumentationshilfe
für den einen oder anderen neben den von
dir genannten
aspekten animals fragt uns über youtube
warum werden eigentlich nicht sofort
gelder für das gesundheitssystem zur
verfügung gestellt die betten und kräfte
sind da bzw wären dann vielleicht mehr
da also warum wenig also offenbar dass
der hintergrund der frage warum so wenig
geld für das gesundheitssystem ist diese
kritik berechtigt müsste da sofort mehr
geld zur verfügung gestellt werden wie
verläuft da die diskussion ja da war
jens spahn noch geschäftsführender
gesundheitsminister vergangene woche ich
glaube es war vergangene woche
vielleicht war es auch vor zwei wochen
in der allwöchentlichen
pressekonferenz die er ja hier auf
einladung der bundespressekonferenz
zusammen mit
lothar wieler dem präsidenten des
robert koch-instituts gibt
da war er sehr klar und zwar ist der
pflege bonus ein erneuter pflege bonus
wieder im gespräch und das machen
politiker eigentlich ungern aber sparen
der hat er natürlich jetzt auch den
vorteil dass er demnächst nicht mehr
verantwortlich ist das kommt noch hinzu
hat er eine zahl in den mund genommen
und sprach von 5000 euro plus und
weitete den kreis auch aus und sagte
nicht nur pfleger und pflegerinnen
sondern auch zum beispiel die hygiene
die putzkräfte auf den intensivstationen
die müssen damit einbezogen werden das
heißt
man ist sich des problems bewusst dass
pflegekräfte angemessen vergütet werden
müssen die jetzt wirklich seit beginn
der pandemie ja quasi durchgearbeitet
haben während der wellen und daneben
auch das darf man nicht vergessen
zwischen den corona wählen dann ja
verschobene operationen nachgeholt haben
da also auch sehr gefragt waren nicht
ohne grund sind ja nun auch weniger
pflegekräfte überhaupt noch im job
manche haben hingeschmissen verschaffung
von frustration dass insgesamt mehr geld
in die pflege gepumpt werden muss war
auch schon vor corona klar aber wo ein
wille ist auch nicht immer gleich geld
da das wird sicherlich steht auch im
koalitionsvertrag ein thema sein dessen
sich die ampel schleunigst annehmen wird
müssen weil vom thema pflege noch mal
gesprochen hast ich hatte vorhin schon
einen beitrag an moderiert auch eben
genau dazu jetzt stellt sich die frage
ob wir diesen beitrag den inzwischen
sehen können weil für hin lag er dann
ein anderer weiter vor jetzt höre ich
wir hören ihnen also dann geht das auch
noch mal über die probleme in der pflege
auch gerade vor dem hintergrund dass man
die sorge hat wenn man dort eine
impfpflicht 1 führt das dann der eine
oder andere mitarbeiter die ein oder
andere mitarbeiterinnen aufhören könnte
sandra schäfer ist pflegekraft sie liebt
ihren beruf doch seit der pandemie sind
sie im altenheim st franziskus in
kolbermoor im dauerstress in der ersten
welle sind 16 menschen hier gestorben
die aktuellen hohen inzidenz 'nen aber
auch die neue virusvariante belasten die
stimmung ist einfach sehr gedrückt und
wir haben wahnsinnige angst vor der
vierten welle die folge allein in ihrem
bereich haben sich drei von fünf
pflegekräften krankgemeldet sie selbst
leidet unter longo witt weiß was das
virus anrichten kann umso wichtiger sei
dass impfen doch einige ihrer
kolleginnen sind nicht geimpft das
spaltet definitiv das team also man hat
nur die geimpften und dann human power
aus und stehen der wirt song also man
versucht natürlich nicht zu werten oder
unbewusst wackers schussmann
ist 92 sie war an corona erkrankt ist
bereits gepostet dass manche
pflegekräfte nicht geimpft sind stört
sie
lassen
die angekündigte impfpflicht für
pflegekräfte findet die rüstige dame gut
negative folgen befürchtet man bei der
caritas die ohnehin angespannte
personelle situation könnte sich
verschärfen das tatsächlich von den
bestehenden mitarbeitenden der ein oder
andere sagt so jetzt langt's mir
endgültig ich gehe ich suche mir eine
andere aufgabe margitta leiminger
arbeitet als hauswirtschafts hilfe im
heim die 41-jährige ist nicht geimpft
für sie steht fest wenn es dann so
wirklich hart kommt dass die sagen sie
müssen sich impfen dann würde ich einen
neuen weg suchen für mich und kündigen
für heimleiter jakob hartmann eine
unerträgliche situation
ich merke dass wir ständig versuchen den
ungeimpften nicht auf die füße zu treten
und auf der anderen seite nähert ob ich
mich dabei wie ich eine unendliche wut
habe dass die leute sich nicht hin zu
lassen von 130 beschäftigten sind 15
ungeimpft ersatz für sie zu finden auch
im ländlichen bereich nahezu chancenlos
informationen auch hier noch mal in
unsere social media kanäle seien youtube
tor adler schreibt ich bin pflegekraft
und höre jetzt auf wegen der impfpflicht
also vielleicht da gerade noch mal an
die an diesem punkt angesetzt auch
nochmal mit nicole diekmann gesprochen
in berlin also das ist offenbar doch
nach wie vor ein großes
kommunikationsproblem das ist da ebenso
viele auch in diesem bereich
wollen wo es gerade besonders darauf
ankommen würde da kann man ja außer im
prinzip du hast das fenster gesagt mit
einer pflicht eigentlich gar nicht mehr
weiter durchdringen nur dann hat man
wiederum das problem dass leute aufhören
wie kommt man aus diesem schlamassel
wieder raus ja das ist eine gute frage
ich fand diesen heimleiter gerade im
beitrag sehr eindrücklich der genau da
in der klemme steckt er braucht die
leute will sie nicht verlieren kann aber
nicht nachvollziehen warum sich leute
warum sich menschen die sich um
schwerkranke menschen beziehungsweise um
die sogenannten arabien kümmern die also
anfälliger sind die viel empfindlicher
sind ersten sich anzustecken und
zweitens auch mit einem schwereren
verlauf rechnen müssen ja warum sich die
leute die sich um die kümmern nicht
impfen lassen interessant ist wenn man
nach frankreich blickt unser
korrespondent thomas walde hat das vor
ein paar wochen getwittert da gab es
schon vor einiger zeit die einführung
einer impfpflicht eben für pflegeberufe
und da hat kaum jemand hingeschmissen
das ist natürlich jetzt einfach zu sagen
na ja wir gucken mal was dann passiert
aber das könnte ein beleg dafür sein das
ist vielleicht dann doch nicht so weit
kommen dass die leute die jetzt sagen
dann suche ich mir was anderes
gering in gewisser anteil peters
vielleicht machen aber ob das am ende
des tages dann tatsächlich alle machen
die müssen nämlich auch erst mal was
neues finden das kann man natürlich so
definitiv nicht sagen das ist dahin
gestellt aus diesem dilemma käme man
spreche jetzt nicht juristisch das ist
natürlich sarah spirit aus diesem
dilemma käme man natürlich raus wenn es
eine allgemeine impfpflicht gebe und
nicht nur eine berufsbezogene ja
vielleicht gerade das nochmal verbunden
genau sarah die frage an dich eben mit
der äußerung hier von heiko wirklich
über facebook impfpflicht für bestimmte
berufe ist nicht rechtens entweder alle
oder keiner ich glaube da nicht recht
es gibt zwar ein gleichheitsgrundsatz
aber hier gibt es eine begründen
begründung wieso man nicht eine
impfpflicht für alle macht sondern für
spezifische berufsgruppen weil von
personen die in der pflege arbeiten oder
in krankenhäusern arbeiten eine
besondere gefahr ausgeht weil sie in
kontakt mit menschen sind die wenn sie
infiziert sind eben in der regel schwere
verläufe haben und sterben das heißt sie
gefährden andere ungleich mehr das heißt
hier zu sagen wir machen
für diese beruflich ist sogar im
gegenteil nicht nur nicht rechtlich
möglich sondern sogar das mildere mittel
als alle zu verpflichten weil diese
besondere gefahr geht eben nicht von der
gesamtheit der bevölkerung aus sondern
von dieser spezifischen gruppe
nichtsdestotrotz ist es auch eine
möglichkeit zusage macht eine allgemeine
empfiehlt auch die gilt aber in jedem
fall möglich ist es zu sagen wie in dem
medizinisches personal besonders die
pflicht weil sie andere menschen eben
besonders gefährden zu dieser äußerung
passt auch noch mal von modena der
kommentar er sagt über youtube wenn ich
das höre dann sollte man die impfpflicht
nicht ausschließlich auf das
pflegepersonal legen sondern alle in den
einrichtungen und nicht nur dort sondern
auch bei einzelhandel und so weiter also
im prinzip eine allgemeine impfpflicht
wenn ich das richtig verstehe und dazu
hast du dich ja gerade auch schon
geäußert dass das auch rechtlich möglich
sein müsste wir haben noch eine weitere
zuschriften über facebook wie wäre es
mit 2g auch am arbeitsplatz wieso dort
3g interessant warum unterscheidet man
am arbeitsplatz zwischen 2g und 3g
ähnlich wie es auch kein zweig für
supermärkte geht und auch kein zweig in
der bahn geht weil es weiterhin möglich
sein muss dass man arbeiten geht wenn
man ungeimpfte sodass bald muss
weiterhin möglich sein wer mit der bahn
zu fahren oder im supermarkt einzukaufen
das heißt da macht man dann die 3g
lösung weil man nicht menschen an an dem
wir nennen es
sind gemeinschaftseinrichtungen ist die
geschäfte des täglichen bedarfs ist es
in dem fall und es ist einfach also also
grundrecht auch arbeiten gehen zu dürfen
deswegen kann man da nicht ungeimpfte
solange man keine allgemeine impfpflicht
ausschließen feuerkraft schreibt uns
über youtube ich bin dafür dass die
massnahmen verschärft werden müssen
jedoch sollten lokale möglichkeiten zur
einschränkung erweitert werden die
zahlenden deutschland sind einfach zu
unterschiedlich wie es da die
einschränkung also ist das ohne weiteres
möglich dass man sagt okay wir haben
hier unterschiedliche bereiche
unterschiedliche also auf länder ebene
sowieso aber vielleicht auch
unterschiedlich landkreise dass man sagt
okay man macht da tatsächlich
unterschiedlich namen recht langweilig
er sagt er ist dafür dass man bevor man
mit allgemeinen maßnahmen kommt dass man
erst mal die lokalen möglichkeiten
ausdifferenzierter macht und dass man
sagt okay also wenn halt irgendwo
wirklich ein hotspot ist dass man da
vielleicht andere regeln macht als zb in
gebieten wo die zahlen nicht so hoch
sind genau das ist ja grundsätzlich auch
so angelegt deswegen also früher waren
es die inzidenz werde jetzt ist die
hospitalisierung dass manche menschen
sind im krankenhaus grundsätzlich ist
das richtig und auch so angelegt weil
natürlich in einem landkreis oder auch
in einem bundesland wo sehr viel weniger
menschen infiziert sind die auch eine
ganz andere gefahrenlage ist
gleichzeitig aber möglich und das steht
auch in diesem beschluss papier hatte
dass man das vorhat zu sagen wir machen
bestimmte wir schaffen bestimmte strenge
mindeststandards auch damit selbst in
den bundesländern die aktuell nicht so
stark betroffenen schon präventiv
gehandelt wird und in anderen
bundesländern die stark betroffenen die
können auch über diese mindeststandards
hinausgehen und noch schärfere regeln
setzen aber wir wollen einfach
deutschlandweit scharfen einheitliche
mindeststandards schaffen und das ist
grund gesetzlich möglich und
wahrscheinlich praktisch auch sinnvoll
da deutschlandweit einheitliche
standards zu schaffen
ok also das wäre auch möglich und du
sagst sogar vielleicht sogar auch
sinnvoll dann wollen wir noch mal auf
die medizinische ebene abheben wenn wir
die verbindung haben zu hören dr stürmer
ist wieder bei uns wunderbar ich freue
mich schon dass sie wieder da sind herr
dr stürmer wir sind immer noch na ja wir
waren zwischenzeitlich ein bisschen mehr
bei den politischen rechtlichen
dimensionen aber natürlich kriegen wir
nach wie vor viele zuschriften was das
medizinische angeht und es geht auch da
hauptsächlich noch mal um die äußerungen
von herrn mertens wir haben jetzt schon
mehrfach darüber gesprochen also die
sorge dass man eventuell kinder doch
noch nicht impfen lassen sollte weil er
gesagt hat in einem interview er würde
sein siebenjähriges enkel kennt im
moment noch nicht impfen lassen die
frage an uns in den usa und in israel
wird ja bereits geimpft gibt es damit
der nicht schon genügend erfahrungswerte
was wissen sie darüber
ja ganz genau dass hinter die daten die
sich die ständige impfkommission jetzt
anschaut und entsprechend in den kontext
setzt und bis dato haben wir jetzt
eigentlich keine signale gehört die
jetzt darauf hinweisen dass es da in
dieser altersgruppe besonders probleme
gibt man muss ja dazu sagen der dosis
des impfstoffes ist ja ein drittel
dessen was die erwachsenen bekommen also
mache ich das schon eben auch rücksicht
genommen auf den zustand
entwicklungszustand der kinder und
dementsprechend bin ich immer noch
optimistisch dass wir da keine weiteren
zusätzlichen signale sehen werden noch
mal die frage wir können das ja einfach
immer mal wieder aufgreifen sie haben es
mit sicherheit auch schon öfter
beantwortet aber nichtsdestotrotz die
fragen gibt es immer noch was ist mit
langzeitschäden mit seltenen
nebenwirkungen wie herzmuskelentzündung
vielleicht auch in dem zusammenhang
nochmal die frage wenn es um
langzeitschäden geht dann haben
mediziner da glaube ich ein anderes
verständnis von als die
normalbevölkerung weil es wird ja jetzt
schon oft gesagt wir haben
langzeitstudien dabei gibt es ja die
impfung noch gar nicht so lange also
jetzt im zeithorizont eines laien
gedacht wie muss man dass sich
vorstellen also wenn jetzt jemand wissen
will na ja aber in zehn jahren oder in
20 jahren beweist denn was ich dann
davon bekommen habe oder dadurch
erlitten habe das ist aber nicht die art
und weise wie die medizin in diesem
bereich funktioniert
nein es ist so dass wir uns jetzt zum
anfang zweimal haben impfen lassen jetzt
ein drittes mal mit einem booster
impfung in tome impfen lassen und das
war es da sind ja erst mal wie mengen
die dieser
impfstoffmengen was in unseren körper
kommt marginal da ist nichts was ich
großartig immo anlagen kann und über die
zeit irgendwelchen unsinn anrichten kann
das ist anders wenn ich medikamente
nehme die ich täglich oder wöchentlich
nehmen muss da kann natürlich immer ein
potenzial sein das über die zeit sich da
irgendwas auf türen was ich vielleicht
in den studien nicht gesehen habe weil
die zu kurz gelaufen sind das ist beim
impfen völlig anders ich impfe die
effekt kommt sofort das immunsystem
reagiert und wenn es reagiert hat ist
feierabend denn ist der impfstoff
abgebaut dann sind die virus proteine
abgebaut das immunsystem hat seine
aufgabe gemacht den körper wieder
gereinigt von dieser leuten infektion in
anführungszeichen ja und da passiert
nichts auch der lang hat er in der
langen zeit was die meisten menschen
falsch verstehen ist folgendes wenn ich
jetzt zum beispiel eine ganz seltene
nebenwirkung lassen sie es einen bei
einer von einer million impfungen
auftauchen sehen dann brauche ich
natürlich wenn ich nur 100.000 impfungen
im jahr habe mit diesem impfstoff sehr
viel zeit um diese nebenwirkung zu sehen
einfach statistisch weil ich eine weile
brauchen bis sich die million voll haben
und meistens brauche ich ja immer ein
bisschen mehr
das ist hier völlig anders weil dem
corona impfstoffen wir haben so viele
menschen weltweit geben dass wir auch
die seltensten nebenwirkungen auch in
der ganz kurzen zeit schon selten sehen
müssen und dementsprechend brauchen wir
keine langzeitstudien weil sie gar nicht
notwendig sind impfstoffe machen in der
form keine langzeit nebenwirkungen und
die zeit die wir brauchen um sie mit
nebenwirkungen sehen zu können die es
gar nicht nötig über längeren zeitraum
zu haben weil er schon so viele menschen
weltweit geben ja ich glaube das ist ein
ganz wichtiger zusammenhang den sie
gerade noch einmal erläutert haben und
ich glaube das ist eben wirklich für
viele leute schwierig zu verstehen dass
man sagt ja wie langzeitstudien ich weiß
doch noch eben gar nicht was in ein paar
jahren sein wird genau also gut dass sie
das noch mal aufgegriffen haben dass das
eben bei impfungen anders als bei
medikamenten so gar nicht sinnvoll ist
diese betrachtung kurze nur verständnis
frage weil ich die möglichkeit machten
wir halt so sehr diese
herzmuskelentzündung die in israel
gemeldet wurden das heißt die sind dann
auch innerhalb der ersten 12 tage
aufgetreten also wie schnell ist der
impfstoff aus dem körper ab wann ist
quasi also dass man keine ahnung eine
halbseitige gesichtslähmung zehn tage
später ist dann komisch dass es mit der
impfung irgendwie zeitnah zusammenhängt
kann aber nicht mehr mit der impfung
zusammenhängen also wann ist der
impfstoff raus wie nas dieser zeitliche
zusammenhang
ich muss ehrlich gestehen ich kenne
einen ganz genauen zeitpunkt wo man
jetzt den schnitt macht und sagt okay
alles was ich drei oder vier wochen der
lage ist beobachten wir nicht mehr oder
berücksichtigt berücksichtigen wir nicht
mehr mindestens 14 tage denke ich sollte
man schon eine korrelation auf jeden
fall
berücksichtigen dass also da was
passiert aber wenn es über monate oder
gar jahre geht das ist definitiv nicht
nicht der fall also es ist sicherlich
ein sehr kurzer zeitraum wir sprechen
über über wochen johanna schwarzer über
facebook schreibt uns warum reden die
politiker nicht über die tod impfstoffe
es gibt so viele leute die auf diesen
impfstoff
was ist dazu zu sagen und ist diese
erwartung diese hohe erwartungen
eigentlich berechtigt wenn man den jetzt
vergleicht mit dem was schon auf dem
markt ist
das argument der tod impfstoffe das
hören wir natürlich sehr häufig einfach
auch der aufgrund der tatsache dass das
ein bewährtes im prinzip ist was ja
schon seit seit jahren und jahrzehnten
verwenden und viele menschen jede menge
technik oder der vector technik
misstrauen die sagen als sie wollen die
sind tot im stoff haben gut da kommt
jetzt demnächst aber jetzt in der
pandemie wird die schnell fortschreiten
zu können kommt er wahrscheinlich zu
spät und ich gebe 1 zu bedenken wenn man
jetzt schon über nebenwirkungen vorhin
gesprochen haben tod im stoffe brauchen
damit sie funktionieren einen
sogenannten im verstärker und diese
immer stärker das sind die bestandteile
der impfstoffe die häufig wirklich die
probleme machen dieser vermeiden wollen
autoimmunreaktionen in dieser richtung
zum beispiel generieren die hat weder
nmr an dem stoff noch rauch die direktor
impfstoff insofern ist das warten auf
den tod im stoff auf der einen seite von
der methode her irgendwo ein bisschen
nachvollziehbar auf der anderen seite
nimmt man mehr nebenwirkungen kauft und
ich sagte ja schon die jetzt verwendeten
impfstoffe vector impfstoff impfstoffe
sind so häufig in der welt eingesetzt
worden das ist kaum eine bessere
sicherheit datensicherheits überblick
gibt als als mit diesen impfstoffen also
ist es offenbar auch eher so ein
psychologisches argument oder ein grund
warum die leute noch warten weil sie
dieses verfahren eben kennen
johanna schwarzer die hatte ich gerade
vorgelesen plextor nochmal er sagt eine
impfpflicht mit einem impfstoff der
nicht gegen omikron wirkt ist unlogisch
ja das ist jetzt die frage wie gut
wirken die bisher bekannten impfstoffe
gegen omikron was weiß man bislang
also man weiß eigentlich noch nichts
wirklich definitives wir gehen davon aus
weil das nikon hat ja einen sehr starken
mutierten oberflächen montiertes
oberflächenprotein das protein wir
müssen davon ausgehen dass einige
bindungsstellen die unser immunsystem
sozusagen anvisiert hat jetzt nicht mehr
angreifbar sind und erst wieder erlernt
werden müssten auf der anderen seite ist
im monat fort ja immer sehr variabel und
sehr vielseitig deswegen denke ich auch
dass es genug angriffspunkte noch gibt
wo der impfstoff auch weiterhin system
durch den impfstoff induziert weiterhin
angreifen kann es ist davon auszugehen
dass nikon auch mit den bisherigen
impfstoffen
gut in schach gehalten werden kann
welchen prozentsatz letztendlich die
wirksamkeit liegt kann man jetzt noch
nicht vorhersagen das steht noch ein
bisschen in den sternen aber das wird
jetzt die nächste zeit hoffentlich
zeigen weil da wird natürlich kräftig
geforscht habe du bist sofort dran wir
wollten gerade noch mal schauen
gemeinsam auf die aktuellen bilder aus
berlin denn da tut sich immerhin ein
bisschen was also wir sehen zwar noch
weder frau merkel noch herrn scholz aber
immerhin ist ein bisschen bewegung in
der ganzen sache und es könnte also
durchaus sein das ist dann vorhin hieß
es nämlich zehn minuten das ist jetzt
aber schon wieder drei minuten her also
es könnte es hat sich da jetzt die
fotografen stehen auch schon mit der
kamera im anschlag also könnte jetzt
jederzeit soweit sein sarah du wolltest
dich auch noch mal
hatte ich einige rollo gefragt weil es
da hab ich mich gefragt wie findet man
heraus
ob man nun die delta variante oder mit
omikron infiziert ist also der pcr test
zeigt das ja erst mal nicht an
wahrscheinlich da gibt es dann
verdachtsmoment dass man speziell darauf
dann noch mal getestet wird oder wie ist
da der ablauf
der test an sich zeigt es nicht es ist
so dass wir erst mal eine verordnung
haben in deutschland wo wir als labor
verpflichtet sind zwischen fünf und zehn
prozent der positiven proben zur
sequenzierung also zur feinanalyse der
varianten abzugeben zwar selber zu
untersuchen und zusätzlich fahren die
meisten labore eine sogenannte varianten
analyse mit der man einzelne
veränderungen abfragt und schaut ob die
vorhanden sind und der hätte und auch
mikron unterscheiden sich doch sehr
stark in dem mutations muster und wir in
frankfurt nutzen zum beispiel ein essay
mit dem wir das mit einem einem einem
test sozusagen sehr sehr sauber
nachweisen können ob die älter oder auch
mikron vorliegt wo wir gerade bei
omikron sind also das wurde in südafrika
zum ersten mal festgestellt was nicht
heißt dass es daher kommt das vielleicht
auch noch mal wichtig aber die haben ja
dort auch ein sehr gutes system um das
zu sequenzieren
afrika hat mit einer also das ist jetzt
pauschal afrika wir haben jetzt gerade
in südafrika gesprochen afrika hat mit
einer sehr geringen impfrate keinerlei
probleme naja ob das so stimmt weiß ich
auch nicht wir haben eine hohe impfrate
und massive probleme wie kann das sein
dass eine frage von till dorf schmidt
über youtube könnte mir vorstellen dass
es auch mit der altersstruktur der
bevölkerung zusammenhängt
ja das ist auf jeden fall etwas was
damit zusammenhängt man kann tatsächlich
auch teilweise ja die europäischen
länder nicht eins zu eins vergleichen
was so die die auswirkungen der pandemie
angeht und schon gar nicht über die
kontinente es ist die altersstruktur es
mag vielleicht ethnische unterschiede
geben die das auch die die
virusvermehrung oder die die schwere der
infektion
beeinflussen wir kennen das virus noch
nicht mal zwei jahre ist noch viele
dinge die unerforscht sind
möglicherweise in spielen in afrika auch
andere klimatische hintergründen der
rolle da sind viele faktoren die dafür
sorgen können dass wir tatsächlich in
afrika deutlich weniger dramatisch
zustände sehen als sie am anfang
befürchtet haben das ist ein phänomen
dem man natürlich auch nach geht und
versucht herauszufinden woran das im
detail liegt aber deswegen jetzt schluss
argumentieren zu wollen das alles seien
da geht es uns so gut wie in afrika das
ist definitiv ein trugschluss
vielleicht weil sie es für ihn auch
angesprochen hatten im vergleich von
impfstoffen mit medikamenten das ist ja
vielleicht auch noch mal ganz
interessant zu wissen wie weit sind wir
denn eigentlich was die forschung an
entsprechenden medikamenten angeht also
wir reden viel über die impfung viel
über impfpflicht inzwischen auch aber
man könnte ja auch auf die idee kommen
dass wir uns sozusagen von zwei seiten
in die zange zu nehmen also das wird
natürlich auch untersucht und geforscht
oder was ist da der stand der dinge
da geht es jetzt darum die die möglichen
schweren verläufe abzumildern weil wenn
wir die infektion erst mal haben dann
ist das ja nicht mehr präventiv also
medikamente zur prävention haben wir
definitiv nicht was es gibt sind eben
diese antikörper cocktails da mag es ein
bisschen problematisch bei den varianten
seien weil das sind sogenannte
monoklonale antikörper die haben nur
eine bindungsstelle und wenn die
natürlich bei nikon zum beispiel
verändert ist dann wirken diese dinge
nicht aber es gibt auch ein medikament
was sehr gute wirksamkeit zeigt also da
ist schon einiges auch passiert und wird
die entwicklung auch weiter gehen also
wir haben auch einiges im arsenal
inzwischen was eben auch dazu beitragen
kann die verläufe deutlich milder zu
gestalten zocker aus leidenschaft
schreibt uns über youtube der impfstoff
ist meiner meinung nach noch nicht
ausgereift okay das ist eine meinung
trotz impfung noch große
ansteckungsgefahr wird wird nicht weg
sein wir müssen lernen damit zu leben
was den letzten teil seiner äußerungen
angeht damit könnte er recht haben wir
müssen lernen damit zu leben aber die
werden wir dann in zukunft ihrer
einschätzung nach damit leben werden wir
uns all halbjährlich dann neue impfen
lassen müssen wie wird das sein
also werden wir reden über die erste
generation der impfstoffe und wir reden
sozusagen über die erste impfstrategie
die wir überhaupt ausprobiert haben und
dafür sind stehen wir sehr gut da man
darf nicht vergessen ein booster nach
einem halben jahr heißt nicht dass der
zweite booster auch nach einem halben
jahr kommen muss sondern ein booster ist
ja in der regel nicht nur ein verlängern
sozusagen der frist um den gleichen
zeitraum sondern eine verstärkung und
dementsprechend ist davon auszugehen
dass nach der booster impfung die
immunität deutlich länger stabil bleibt
natürlich müssen wir da noch mehr
erfahrungen sammeln natürlich gehe ich
davon aus dass die impfstoffe auch nicht
in der form bleiben wie sie sind je
nachdem was noch alles an varianten
kommt oder ob nicht vielleicht auch
schon am nikon ein indikator sein wird
gegen impfstoff anzupassen wir kennen es
von der grippeimpfung die influenza ist
auch ein sehr variables virus wir
kriegen jedes jahr ein vierfach cocktail
an impfstoffen vier varianten drin die
angepasst sind an das
infektionsgeschehen auf der welt und
kann mir sehr gut vorstellen dass wir
ähnliche verfahren auch bei lars koch
zwei etablieren werden aber da muss man
ein bisschen geduld haben das schafft
man jetzt nicht in den anderthalb jahren
oder in dem einen jahr wurde erst impfen
ich finde dafür sind wir verdammt gut ja
das kann man ja an der stelle wo ich
auch noch mal betonen dass das in vielen
teilen auch schon ganz gut angelaufen
ist was ist mit einer risikoabwägung
werden wir gefragt was ist risikoreicher
eine impfung oder eine infektion ich
glaube das können sie relativ schnell
beantworten denn auf eins von beidem
läuft ist ja dann doch hinaus ja ganz
klar die infektion wir müssen nun mal
wieder die die herzmuskelentzündung ins
spiel bringen die wurden ja auch schon
mal angedeutet eine sehr seltene
nebenwirkung auch beim impfen mit
moderner wohl bei den jungen menschen
etwas häufiger als wird bei und deswegen
eine angepasste empfehlung auch von der
stiko aber eine herzmuskelentzündung bei
der normalen infektion ist deutlich
häufiger und insofern einfach nur ein
wiesn mal beispiel gezeigt infektion
gilt es immer zu vermeiden gerade mit
einem erreger von dem man noch längst
nicht alles weiß
ganz kurz sarah wollte was sagen ich
bitte sie dass diese genau diesen
gedanken für sich zu behalten denn wir
sehen dass frau merkel und auch herr
scholz und auch herr müller und auch er
wüst von run auf das podium schreiten
und wir geben direkt nach berlin der
kommende bundeskanzler die noch
bundeskanzlerin wie jetzt gerade wieder
zurück läuft ich hoffe sie haben nichts
wesentliches vergessen
kommt dann hoffentlich auch gleich
wieder mit dazu und dann wird es in
wenigen momenten losgehen also wir sind
bei der pressekonferenz melden uns dann
danach zurück
meine damen und herren guten tag die
bundeskanzlerin der vizekanzler und die
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten haben ihre
beratungen beendet und wenn sie jetzt
über die beschlüsse informieren das wort
hat die bundeskanzlerin
meine damen und herren wir haben in der
tat noch einmal beraten
und dies vor der situation dass die lage
in unserem land ernst ist was die
chorakademie anbelangt und
dass die belastung in den krankenhäusern
auch teilweise an die grenzen gerät wir
sehen das auch an der tatsache dass
patienten verlegt werden und deshalb
waren wir heute von einem akt der
nationalen solidarität gesprochen damit
wir sinkende infektionszahlen bekommen
und unser gesundheitssystem eben nicht
überlasten sondern entlasten in diesem
zusammenhang
ist auch nochmal hier aufgeführt unserem
beschlusspapier was wir ihnen schon
berichtet hatten bezüglich des
krisenstabs und der imf ziele 30
millionen impfungen
angefangen zu rechnen vom 18 november
bis zum jahresende und dafür eben auch
die notwendigen organisatorischen
maßnahmen der impfstatus wird nicht
dauerhaft anerkannt werden können als
doppelt geimpft und damit abgeschlossen
geben sondern es wird ja auch auf der
ebene der eu diskutiert da es noch neun
monaten der die zweite impfung ihrer
gültigkeit verliert das heißt dass
boostern das nach imst das auf mischung
simpson ist ganz wichtig um dann als
vollständig games zu gelten aber
natürlich werden die übergangszeiten so
sein dass jeder auch eine chance hat
seinen impfstatus wieder zu erneuern
wir werden bundesweit einen zugang zu
einrichtungen und veranstaltungen der
kultur freizeitgestaltung
unabhängig von der instanz nur für die
ängste und gelesene ermöglichen es kann
ergänzend auch ein test noch einmal
zweig plus genannt gefordert werden die
2g regeln der auch auf den einzelhandel
ausgeweitet ausgenommen sind die
geschäfte des täglichen bedarfs er soll
für alle privaten zusammenkünfte oder
kontakte dann eine strikte grenze geben
wenn sich ein nicht geimpfte personen
dabei befindet und zwar geht es darum
dann den eigenen haushalt sowie
höchstens zwei personen eines weiteren
haushalts also überall wo nicht alle
teilnehmer geimpft und genesen sind gilt
diese grenze eigene haushalts sowie
höchsten zwei weitere personen kinder
bis zur vollendung des 14 jahres sind
hiervon ausgenommen
wir haben sehr lange mit überregionalen
sport kultur und vergleichbaren
großveranstaltung beschäftigt vielleicht
können die ländervertreter dazu dann
nachher etwas sagen
spätestens ab einer inzidenz von mehr
als 350 neuinfektionen in sieben tagen
pro 100000 einwohner werden clubs und
diskotheken in innenräumen geschlossen
und
es ist dann auch so dass wir
sagen dass dies jetzt rechtlich schon
möglich wäre aber es wird noch einmal
gemeinsam
verändert in kreisen mit einer incidents
oberhalb von 350 1 350 fällen pro
100.000 einwohner und sieben tagen
müssen alle kontakte reduziert werden
und deshalb gilt für private feiern und
zusammenkünfte eine teilnehmer grenze
von 50 personen also geimpfte und
genesene in innenräumen und 200 personen
geimpfte und genesene im außenbereich
für die wohl ungeimpfte dabei sind hatte
ich ja erst schon die
maßgabe gesagt in schulen geht alle
masken pflicht eine strenge kontrolle
der regeln wird durchgesetzt und es geht
um die weiterentwicklung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
das ist jetzt eine gesetzgebungsarbeit
die dann bis zum 15 dezember ja auch die
regelung ersetzen kann oder erweitern
kann die jetzt einen übergangszeitraum
hatten hierzu kann vielleicht auch noch
mal von olaf scholz etwas gesagt werden
weil das ja auch die gesetzgebung der
zukünftigen ampel koalition anbelangt
müssen
noch darauf hin dass alle von uns
genannten maßnahmen quasi
mindeststandards sind das heißt länder
können strenger vorgehen und wir haben
uns noch einmal zur impfpflicht geäußert
eine allgemeine impfpflicht soll im
deutschen bundestag diskutiert und
entschieden werden dazu bitten bund und
länder den ethikrat sich bis jahresende
eine empfehlung zu erarbeiten und dann
kann diese
allgemeine impfpflicht könnte bei
entsprechender entscheidung greifen etwa
ab februar
2022 es wird ein expertengremium von
wissenschaftlern und wissenschaftlern
eingerichtet wir haben uns mit dem
silvester und neujahr
beschäftigt das würde ich auch hendrik
wüst überlassen und wir haben uns noch
einmal zu den wirtschafts hilfen
verständigt überbrückungshilfe 4 die
natürlich angesichts der einschränkungen
von großer bedeutung sind sie sehen an
den beschlüssen dass wir verstanden
haben dass die lage sehr ernst ist und
dass wir durch weitergehende maßnahmen
zusätzlich zu den jetzt schon getroffene
maßnahmen im infektionsschutzgesetz noch
einmal dass insbesondere auch in hoch
inzidenz gebieten handeln wollen um
wirklich die arbeit die stündlich und
auch jetzt zu dieser zeit wieder in den
intensivstationen geleistet wird nicht
nur anzuerkennen sondern möglichst auch
weniger notwendig zu machen und dazu
muss die vierte welle gebrochen werden
und das ist bis jetzt noch nicht
geschafft sie haben im augenblick eine
gewisse beruhigung aber auf einem viel
zu hohen niveau und deshalb waren diese
maßnahmen notwendig heute zu beschließen
herr vizekanzler
wir sind in einer sehr sehr schwierigen
situationen wie alle wissen die hat
etwas damit zu tun dass wir zwar sehr
sehr viele geimpfte bürgerinnen und
bürger haben aber nicht genügend viele
um nicht um sicherstellen zu können dass
nicht erneut sich an der infektionswelle
durch das land begibt das ist die
situation mit der wir konfrontiert sind
und das ist klar was wir als allererstes
erreichen müssen das müssen sich
diejenigen noch durch den sich impfen zu
lassen das bisher nicht gemacht haben
und das ist auch an dieser stelle mein
ganz persönlicher appell dass wir alle
überzeugen den schritt jetzt zu gehen es
ist wirklich wichtig und wir wissen
jetzt endgültig das ist eine konsequenz
hat dass ein großer teil der bürger und
bürger sich bisher nicht durchgerungen
hat sich impfen zu lassen und wenn sich
das jetzt ändern kann dann wäre das sehr
sehr wichtig für mich ist das auch etwas
das mit viel emotionen verbunden ist
denn wir wissen doch was für
lagen auf den intensivstationen
entstehen wie schwierig das ist für die
arbeitskräfte dort für die pflegekräfte
für die ärztinnen und ärzte mit der lage
umzugehen damit umzugehen dass viele die
sich nicht haben impfen lassen dort
jetzt um ihr leben ringen und deshalb
müssen wir es schaffen dass wir die
situation ändern und das hat noch einmal
der appell sich impfen zu lassen und für
uns alle gilt dass wir das ganz
ehrgeizige vorhaben gibt es in den
vordergrund stellen müssen viele
erstmalig zu impfen und viele die an der
impfung bereits haben mit einer
zusätzlichen schutz impfung zu versehen
dass boostern ist jetzt eine der ganz
ganz großen herausforderung dar um der
krisenstab den general neuer leiten wird
darum aber auch das ehrgeizige ziel wenn
es denn irgendwie erreichbar ist bis zu
30 millionen impfung alles zusammen zu
erreichen ist weihnachten und die kurze
zeit danach um zu erreichen dass dieser
schutz auch tatsächlich eintritt und wer
die wellen brechen können das ist eine
große logistische herausforderung man
sieht es an den fragen und den
schwierigkeiten über entstehen wenn es
die ärzte und ärzten impfstoff bestellen
wenn überall neue impfzentren
eingerichtet werden die müssen jetzt
laufen das muss alles ineinandergreifen
und genau das haben wir uns vorgenommen
wir wissen dass das ein ehrgeiziges ziel
ist wenn man die verschiedenen impfungen
zusammenrechnet die da seit unserer
letzten mpk unter dem beschluss der
stiko dass alle sich
boost anlassen sollen dass alle eine
auffrischungsimpfung bekommen sollen
seit dieser zeit auf den weg gebracht
haben aber diese kampagne muss jetzt
auch zu ende geführt werden und zwar mit
einem großen ehrgeiz nicht irgendwann
sondern ganz ganz kurzer zeit war das
das wichtigste mittel ist dass wir haben
und daneben brauchen wir natürlich viele
viele der schon genannten sehr
weitreichenden maßnahmen die dazu
beitragen dass die infektionen sich
nicht ausbreiten können die
beschränkungen die wir haben im bereich
von gastronomie und anderen bereichen
für zusammenkünfte 2g und 3g die
beschränkungen im handel mit 2 gb was
jetzt neu ist glaube dass das richtig
und notwendig ist dass wir auch im
privaten bereich kontakt beschränkung
festlegen geben sehr streng sind wenn
ungeimpfte bürgerinnen und bürger dabei
sind notwendigerweise weil das ja eine
der ursachen des infektionsgeschehen es
ist all die anderen dinge sind genannt
worden ich glaube dass es wichtig ist
dass wir klar und präzise sind dass man
sich geeinigt hat und dass das dazu
beitragen kann dass wir jetzt eine
bessere lage gekommen ich bin froh dass
der deutsche bundestag bereits sich auf
den weg gemacht hat darüber zu beraten
eine einrichtung bezogene im pflicht
einzuführen für
einrichtungen in dem besonders
schützenswerte bürgerinnen und bürger da
sind die diesen schutz auch verdient
haben und wofür alles dafür tun müssen
altenpflegeeinrichtung und häuser und
dass wir eine offene abstimmung im
bundestag haben werden über eine
allgemeine impfpflicht der anschlusses
gegeben da glaube ich wird es jetzt auch
vorangehen und aus meiner sicht sollte
es auch zu einer solchen entscheidung
des bundestages kommen ich bin noch
ziemlich sicher dass das der fall sein
wird neben dem krisenstab ja das impfen
boostern begleitet dafür sorgt dass
alles gut funktioniert wollen wir uns
auch regelmäßig neu beraten lassen
deshalb ein expertenrat von
wissenschaftlern und wissenschaftlern
denn eingerichtet wird und er natürlich
nicht nur die bundesregierung und den
bundestag sondern auch die
ministerpräsident und
ministerpräsidenten mit rat und
vorschlägen versehen soll aber es sollen
vorschläge seien die gemeinsam
erarbeitet worden sind die diskutiert
worden sind nicht dass da 15
verschiedenen nebeneinander stehen so
etwas nennt man sich auseinandersetzen
kann und muss dass wir alles dafür tun
dass diese situation besser wird das ist
das was hier gemeinsam sich alle
vorgenommen haben und ich bin froh dass
in dieser schwierigen lage der
schulterschluss funktioniert dass die
parteipolitik in den hintergrund tritt
die gesundheit der bürger und bürger in
den vordergrund des gemeinsamen
politischen bestrebens so soll es die
nächste zeit auch weiter sein es geht um
eine große nationale anstrengung und es
geht um solidarität
herr ministerpräsident wüste
vielen dank im namen der
ministerpräsidentin und
ministerpräsidenten der länder möchte
ich mich an erster stelle war ganz
herzlich bei all denen bedanken die mit
ihrer solidarität helfen dass wir gut
durch die krise kommen und gleichzeitig
alle nicht geimpften dringend aufrufen
die impf angebote wahrzunehmen nicht
erst irgendwann vielleicht im neuen jahr
oder nach weihnachten sondern jetzt sie
retten damit leben unser land ist weiter
in einer schwierigen lage es liegen auch
schwierige wochen noch vor uns die
infektionszahlen sind weiterhin hoch zu
hoch ärzte pflegekräfte sind am limit
und arbeiten teilweise schon lange
darüber hinaus wir haben mit omikron
eine neue gefährliche mutation im land
und das nehmen wir sehr ernst die
ministerpräsidenten von sachsen und
baden württemberg da kamen heute
eindrücklich die lage dargestellt die in
teilen unseres landes eben nicht nur
kritisch ist sondern dramatisch seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg hatten wir in
deutschland keine vergleichbare
situation im gesundheitswesen wir
brauchen deshalb einen akt der
nationalen solidarität das heißt erstens
wir müssen in den nächsten wochen
konsequent kontakte reduzieren nur so
kann diese vierte welle gebrochen werden
und zweitens impfen impfen ist der weg
raus aus dieser schwierigen lage in der
pandemien deshalb müssen sich alle
impfen lassen die sich impfen lassen
können ist es richtig und es ist wichtig
und ist heute auch wirklich gut gewesen
dass wir als länder mit dem bund eine
gemeinsame linie abgestimmt haben jetzt
gemeinsam konsequent handeln wir haben
heute ein umfangreiches paket
beschlossen
umfangreiche kontakt beschränkungen für
ungeimpfte deutliche reduktion der
zuschauer bei überregionalen
großveranstaltung das gilt auch für
spiegel der fußball bundesliga clubs und
diskotheken werden in vielen
bundesländern geschlossen 2g regeln
werden ausgeweitet die wir an dieser
stelle ausdrücklich betonen dass sind
mindeststandards im übrigen haben wir
auch noch mal das feuerwerksverbot fürs
jahresende aus dem letzten jahr
wiederholt auch dass ein mindest in den
betroffenen regionen in den besonders
stark betroffenen regionen
gelten selbstverständlich deutlich
strengere regeln gerade in den hotspots
brauchen die verantwortlichen zur
pandemie bekämpfung zusätzliche optionen
das ist auch in den letzten tagen von
vielen kolleginnen und kollegen deutlich
gemacht worden ist deshalb gut dass herr
scholz für die künftige regierung für
die mehrheit im deutschen bundestag
erklärt hat dass er bereit ist
nachzubessern als interaktions
schutzgesetz des bundes zu überarbeiten
es ist eben besonders wichtig für die
länder mit besonders hohen
infektionszahlen ist die ziffer 14 in
dem beschlusspapier indem der
gesetzgeber gebeten wird das
infektionsschutzgesetz um weitere
regelungen zu ergänzen damit länder und
regionen mit einem besonders hohen
infektionsgeschehen weiterhin
angemessene zusätzliche angebote aber
maßnahmen zum schutz der bevölkerung zur
verfügung haben und darüber hinaus wird
der gesetzgeber gebeten die
übergangsfristen für schutzmaßnahmen im
infektionsschutzgesetz die bis zum 25
november in kraft getreten sind über den
15 dezember hinaus zu verlängern und es
wird gesetzlich klargestellt dass diese
maßnahmen auch regional differenziert
angeordnet werden können das ist ganz
ganz wichtig für regionen mit besonders
hohen infektionszahlen ich bin dankbar
dass das möglich ist liebe frau
bundeskanzlerin zum schluss möchte ich
die gelegenheit nutzen ihnen auch im
namen der ministerpräsident den
ministerpräsidenten ganz herzlich zu
danken die 16 jahre waren gespickt mit
vielen krisen sie haben unser land gut
durch diese teilweise schwierige zeit
geführt in der korona krise stehen sie
nach wie vor dafür den gesundheitsschutz
zur obersten priorität zu machen und
jenseits aller einzelnen fragen hat das
einfach viele menschen leben in
deutschland gerettet deutschland ist in
den bisherigen
gut anderthalb jahren der korona
pandemie besser als andere staaten
durchgekommen ist es ihr verdienst
verehrte frau dr merkel dass sie dabei
auch immer den schulterschluss mit den
ländern gesucht haben wir sind immer
dann besonders stark wenn alle
staatlichen ebenen gemeinsam arbeiten
und zusammen vorankommen wollen und wir
setzen sehr darauf was der nachfolger
hier für kontinuität steht in die länder
auch in zukunft nicht nur dieser frage
als partner sieht will nochmal einmal
zum abschluss sagte merkel in ihrer rede
vom 18 märz erinnern ich darf sie
zitieren seit der deutschen einheit nein
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg gibt es keine
herausforderung an unser land mehr bei
der es so sehr auf unsere gemeinsame auf
unser gemeinsames solidarisches handeln
ankommt was sie damals gesagt haben gilt
auch heute wir müssen alle solidarität
zeigen deshalb noch einmal der ab
reduzieren sie ihre kontakte lassen sie
sich impfen bzw boostern und tragen sie
durch vorsicht dazu bei dass wir diese
vierte welle brechen
regierender bürgermeister müller bitter
wenn dieser winter könnte härter werden
als alles andere was wir bisher in der
pandemie erlebt haben ihr könnt der
härter werden werden wir nicht weiter
entschlossen eingreifen und handeln wir
haben das in den letzten monaten
bewiesen dass wir das können dass wir
eingreifen gerade auch in den letzten
wochen haben viele länder ja schon durch
die maßnahmen die wir ergriffen haben
auch verhindern können dass diese
fördert situation weiter eskaliert oder
sie haben sogar schon erreicht dass es
einen leichten rückgang desinfektions
geschehens gibt will auch betonen dass
auch auf der bundesebene das passiert
ist es wird sehr viel natürlich darüber
gesprochen und berichtet dass die
notlage aufgegeben wurde durch die
entscheidung des deutschen bundestages
aber einhergehend damit waren weitere
massive
möglichkeiten einzugreifen wenn man
alleine
an die 3g regelung am arbeitsplatz denkt
oder auch die entsprechenden home office
regeln sie sind mit beschlossen worden
von der bundesebene und sind weitere
wichtige instrumente im kampf gegen die
pandemie auch für die länder wir haben
heute auch wieder miteinander wichtige
maßnahmen beschlossen die eben schon
dargestellt wurden und ich glaube dass
es uns damit auch gelingen kann dass
sich die situation auf den
intensivstationen nicht weiter zuspitzt
denn dass es ja nach wie vor das maß der
dinge der gesundheitsschutz
sicherzustellen und auch dafür zu sorgen
dass unsere kliniken weiter
leistungsfähig sind und die schwerst
erkrankten gut versorgen können ich bin
sehr froh dass einige dinge die auch in
den ländern auch bei uns in berlin schon
eine rolle spielen jetzt auch bundesweit
verabredet werden konnten wie zum
beispiel auch die 2g regel am
einzelhandel keine einfache situation
für die einzelhändlerin und
einzelhändler das weiß ich die
reaktionen sind auch entsprechend in
berlin aber wir erleben eben auch die
reaktion der kunden die sagen sie finden
es richtig und gut dass so eingegriffen
wird und dass es solche regeln gibt weil
sie sich sicherer fühlen weil sie merken
dass schützt also insofern konnten wir
auch auf diese erfahrung jetzt gut
aufbauen auch andere dinge
einschränkungen bei veranstaltungen zum
beispiel oder überhaupt das umsetzen der
zweig regel ja praktisch in so gut wie
allen lebensbereichen sind denke ich
wichtige maßnahmen man muss es immer
wieder sagen dass es besonders wichtig
ist auch auf die ungeimpften hier zu
reagieren die ungeimpften machen und mal
den großteil der infektion und den stil
schweren fälle auch aus das bedeutet
dass eine gruppe die deutlich in der
minderheit das wir haben inzwischen
bundesweit eine über 70 prozent quote
also das heißt dass eine gruppe die
deutlich in der minderheit es eben die
ungeimpften für die deutliche mehrheit
der infektionen verantwortlich ist und
darauf muss man reagieren
und ich finde es richtig dass wir jeden
satz der frage der partiellen oder
allgemeine impfpflicht jetzt auch
wirklich an einem punkt sind wo das
spürbar ist dass wir darauf reagieren
dass die die die mehrheit darstellen die
vernünftig sind di
verantwortungsbewusst angebote
angenommen haben nämlich die geimpften
dass die möglichkeiten haben die anderen
nicht haben das spiegelt sich auch heute
in unseren verabredungen und in unseren
beschlüssen wieder
letztendlich nicht abschließend aber
auch sagen
alles was wir miteinander beschließen
löst nicht die situation auf dass jeder
auch eigenverantwortlich handeln muss
jeder kann eigenverantwortlich handeln
von institutionen angefangen soll ich an
der stelle auch mal wir sind weit
entfernt von einem wirklichen lockdown
wir haben einschränkend beschlossen aber
wir ermöglichen auch immer noch länger
aber wir ermöglichen dinge wo ein
mindest standard formuliertes und jede
institution für sich auch gruppen kann
kann man nicht noch mehr machen im
übrigen kann auch ein fußball verein mit
seinen fans kontakt aufnehmen und sagen
wir
spielen mit deutlich reduzierter
zuschauerzahl oder vielleicht auch ganz
ohne zuschauer weil uns der
infektionsschutz so wichtig ist dass es
nicht verboten für ein fußball verein so
eine initiative zu ergreifen
genausowenig verboten die auch für
andere institutionen
und mir begegnet in den letzten tagen
ist auch immer wieder dass menschen auf
mich zukommen und sagen ihr schließt da
immer weitere einschränkungen wie wird
denn das kontrolliert es wird doch nicht
funktionieren ohne kontrolle muss
zugeben dass ich ein bisschen staunen
über diese diskussionen weil es so gut
wie keinen lebensbereich gibt in dem wir
uns bewegen wo wir uns nicht auf
grundlage von regeln bewegen die wir
gelernt haben von denen wir wissen dass
sie uns schützen uns und andere schützen
wir beachten sie ohne dass sie lückenlos
kontrolliert werden und wir alle halten
an einer roten ampel und wir wissen das
nicht neben jeder ampel ein polizist
steht der kontrolliert ob wir anhalten
aber wir haben gelernt dass es uns und
andere schützt dass es sicherer ist an
einer roten ampel zu halten warum ist
das eigentlich nicht so
selbstverständlich nach den letzten
anderthalb jahren corona pandemie
möglich also insofern
sage ich ja die politik bleibt in einer
verantwortung rahmenbedingungen zu
setzen das ist unsere aufgabe
und wir kommen dieser aufgabe auch nach
bund wie länder aber es kommt gerade
vielleicht auch für die nächsten monate
noch mal darauf an bis wir eine noch
deutlich höhere impfquote haben auch mit
der durchsetzung der impfpflicht es
kommt für die nächsten monate auch
nochmal auf eigenverantwortung an es
gibt ganz viele die so
eigenverantwortlich schon gehandelt
haben in den letzten monaten und ich
hoffe dass es auch in den nächsten
wochen und monaten immer mehr tun werden
weil sie im wissen wie wichtig es für
unser zusammenleben in einer
solidargemeinschaft ist genau auf solche
regeln die uns und andere schützen auch
zu achten
vielen dank dann kommen wir zu ihren
fragen ich bitte um eine journalistin
angefangen mit herrn rinke von reuters
ich habe meine frage an herrn scholz und
zwar mit blick darauf was gerade das 2g
oder die zweige regelung für den handel
bedeutet es gibt ja schon berechnungen
dass das milliarden einbußen
umsatzeinbußen beim handel bedeuten ist
das jetzt eine auch finanzielle
schleifspur für das was die pandemie
bekämpfung bedeutet können sie dann
umfang geben und nachdem er mueller das
gerade eben erwähnt hatte wie ist das
mit der durchsetzung wie soll in sachsen
wenn in einem landkreis 50 prozent nur
geimpft sind eine solche regel
durchgesetzt werden glauben sie dass das
realistisch ist oder wird das auf
schwierigkeiten stoßen zunächst mal gibt
es ja mehrere länder die bereits zweig
im handel eingeführt haben da kann man
von der praxis lernen und diese praxis
ist gut das gilt zum beispiel auch hier
in berlin da kann das jeder vor ort sich
anschauen das funktioniert aus meiner
sicht sind wir in einer besonderen
situation die meisten bürgern und bürger
haben sich impfen lassen das dürfen wir
ja immer nicht beiseite lassen wenn wir
über die gegenwärtige lage geräten das
ist anders als vor einem jahr dass es
anders als vor dem letzten winter wo die
impfung ist in aussicht standen und noch
gar nicht möglich waren als wir zu
diesem zeitpunkt vor einem jahr zusammen
kommen und deshalb ist es jetzt auch
vertretbar zu sagen es gibt diese
zugangsbeschränkung weil ja jeder und
jede die möglichkeit hat durch eine
eigene impfung die lage für sich zu
verändern und genügend impfstoff zur
verfügung steht und jeder das hätte
längst machen können was müssen wir
gleichzeitig im blick haben dass die
wirtschaftlichen folgen abgefedert
werden genau das ist vorgesehen wir
haben sämtliche wirtschaftshilfen alles
das was wir auf den weg gebracht haben
in den letzten jahren dass wir immer
weiter entwickelt haben was wir immer
umfassender ausführliche ausgestaltet
haben
verlängert und werden dass dies noch
nicht der fall das abschließend auch
noch mal tun so dass sich alle darauf
verlassen können und das ist glaube ich
die gute grundlage dafür ja und
ansonsten gilt natürlich überall in
deutschland impfen booster das ist der
weg aus der krise
herr blank dpa
frau bundeskanzlerin sind sie persönlich
für eine impfpflicht und erlauben sie
eine ganz kurze zweite frage weil es ein
tag des abschieds ist für sie heute die
letzte ministerpräsidenten runde sind
sie erleichtert oder traurig und sehen
sie die krone bekämpfung bei herrn
scholz jetzt in guten händen danken da
sehe ich persönlich glaube nach den
erfahrungen die wir gemacht haben und
wir haben jetzt ja viele viele monate
geworben und dafür uns eingesetzt auf
wahrhaftig allen kanälen dass menschen
sich impfen lassen und müssen trotzdem
sehen dass es impflücken gibt die dazu
führt dass die geimpften doch weiter
eingeschränkt sind und dass das
gesundheitssystem an den rand auch der
überlastung
kommt und zum teil regionalliga auch
überlastet ist und angesichts dieser
situation ist es glaube ich wirklich
auch geboten eine solche impfpflicht zu
beschließen das heißt wäre ich im
deutschen bundestag könnte ich sagen
dass ich mich dafür aussprechen würde
also auch dafür stimmen würde und ich
glaube
wir haben alle gehofft dass die
freiwilligkeit hier besser angenommen
wird wir haben auch gehofft dass die
variante delta vielleicht nicht so
aggressiv ist so dass auch eine
immunität der gemeinschaft schon mit
einer geringeren impfquote erreicht
werden könnte nichts spricht dafür dass
wir das jetzt noch schaffen können und
deshalb ist der weg aus der pandemie die
impfung und deshalb muss man dann auch
diesen schuss fällen so jedenfalls meine
überzeugung ansonsten waren
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen immer
teil meiner politischen meines
politischen tageskalenders oder meiner
politischen agenda sie sind oft
herausfordernd gewesen
und das ist auch nicht verwunderlich
denn der föderalismus ist eine große
stärke deutschlands aber er bedeutet
eben auch dass verantwortung auf
verschiedene ebenen verteilt ist und da
gibt es halt auch unterschiedliche
politische überzeugung und dass wir da
immer auch jetzt in dieser großen
herausforderung sowie hendrik wüst sie
benannt hat zu gemeinsamen beschlüssen
gekommen sind das ist gut und das ist
wichtig und ich denke das wird oder
scholz genau so gelingen er hat ja noch
den vorteil dass er aus der länder
perspektive schon mal gearbeitet hat da
durfte ich ihn auch kennenlernen er weiß
also wie ehrgeizig länder sind ihre
sichtweise durchzusetzen
aber der bund hat ja auch seine
interessen und die wird olaf scholz auch
gut vertreten können frau aigner
deutsche welle
frau bundeskanzlerin haben sie denn das
ziel ihrer kanzlerschaft das ziel dass
sie sich vielleicht selbst gesteckt
haben selbst erreichen können sie in
dieser pandemie deutschland so an olaf
scholz übergeben wie sie sich das mal
vorgestellt hat in deutschland zu
übergeben also ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen dass wir jetzt in einer so starken
vierten welle sind das stimmt mich nicht
froh sondern das bedrückt mich
gerade wenn ich bestimmte regionale
situation sehe und deshalb setze ich
mich und habe ich mich jetzt ja auch bis
zum schluss dafür eingesetzt dass wir
diese vierte welle möglichst schnell
brechen und das hat sich immer wieder
gezeigt dass bundeseinheitliche
maßnahmen hilfreich sind obwohl manches
vielleicht auch regional gemacht werden
könnte und deshalb waren wir das jetzt
auch sehr wichtig dass wir am 18
november und jetzt diese
ministerpräsident konferenz noch mal
hatten ich freue mich auch dass
investition sind das
infektionsschutzgesetz nicht das
investitions gesetz das
infektionsschutzgesetz noch mal
überarbeitet wird und ländern auch die
in not sind bei weitere spielräume gibt
also die lage ist leider ernst und ich
wenn wir eine durchschnittliche
incidents jetzt von
130 wie italien hätten oder 150 wäre es
mir wohler das will ich ganz
ausdrücklich sagen und dass wir unser
gesundheitssystem noch mal so fordern
dass viele menschen auch ihre
operationen auf die sie gehofft haben
die nichts mit krone zu tun haben jetzt
im augenblick nicht bekommen das müssen
uns alle anspornen diese vierte welle
schnell zu brechen aber daran wird ja
gearbeitet und auch wenn ich nicht mehr
da bin für daran weitergearbeitet
herdecker er in de ja
herr scholz eine frage an sie
die der der das ziel eine impfpflicht
einzuführen werden sie daran unter allen
umständen festhalten oder ist auch eine
situation denkbar dass sich jetzt doch
unter dem druck der umfassenden zweig
regel so viele menschen impfen lassen
dass sie im januar oder februar dann zu
dem ergebnis kommen dass das nicht nötig
sein wird und ist das möglicherweise
auch ihre hoffnung
ich glaube
dass es richtig ist dass jetzt diesen
weg gehen und dass der deutsche
bundestag darüber diskutiert weil ja die
ursache unserer gegenwärtigen situation
klar beschrieben werden kann haben sich
nicht gelegen bürgern und bürger impfen
lassen und alles was wir jetzt erleben
alles was sich gegenwärtig umtreibt hat
etwas damit zu tun natürlich würden wir
jetzt auch wenn bei einer höheren
impfquote alles dafür tun dass sich
möglichst viele jetzt an der aufrüstung
holen aber werden nicht diese
dringlichkeit wie wir sie jetzt haben
wir könnten das auch gezielt zügig aber
weniger drastisch angehen als wir es
jetzt machen trotzdem wäre es natürlich
gut wenn wir den effekt hätten das jetzt
schnell die impfquote steigt aber
trotzdem wird es am ende darauf
hinauslaufen müssen dass wir das dann
noch als zielsetzung festhalten weil das
einfach das problem ist dass wir haben
das ist nicht genug sind und das ist
auch der grund warum sich viele ich
eingeschlossen neu
orientiert haben wenn wir eine höhere
infuse hätten dann würden wir jetzt
nicht darüber diskutieren und insofern
ist ihre frage völlig berechtigt aber
wir haben sie nicht und deshalb müssen
wir das jetzt tun
herr jordan city
ja herr scholz
[Musik]
virologen um ärzte sagen dass bei den
hohen infektionszahlen in den nächsten
wochen täglich hunderte menschen
zusätzlich sterben werden haben sie
schon vor ihrem amtsantritt den ersten
großen fehler gemacht indem sie der
bundeskanzlerin nicht schon vor wochen
die parlamentarische unterstützung für
härtere maßnahmen zugesichert haben
und er greift gegenseitig sehr sehr
weitreichende maßnahmen viele maßnahmen
gehen weit über das hinaus was wir im
letzten jahr als
handlungsrahmen überhaupt zur verfügung
hatten wir haben jetzt das erste mal 3g
vorschriften in betrieben wir haben drei
geben öffentlichen verkehr das gab es
bisher nicht wir reden über eine
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht und
wir organisieren
gegenwärtig an der allgemeine
impfpflicht wir haben sehr sehr
weitreichende einschränkung die etwas
mit zweig zu tun haben also dass sich zu
bestimmten orten nur die im und genesene
bürgerinnen und bürger gegeben können
etwas das wir vor sechs monaten noch
nicht machen können weil nicht genügend
diesen status haben erreichen können
weil die
punkte noch nicht hoch genug war was wir
im letzten jahr hätten überhaupt nicht
machen können weil noch gar nicht der
impfstoff zur verfügung stand als wer
auf dezember zuging und deshalb finde
ich es ganz ganz wichtig dass man sich
das immer klar macht es wird im
augenblick mit sehr weitreichenden sehr
drastisch und präzisen maßnahmen auf die
gegenwärtige lage reagiert maßnahmen die
haben das damit zu tun haben dass wir
eine weitgehend geimpfte aber ein nicht
ausreichend geimpfte bevölkerung haben
das muss immer im hinterkopf sein und
deshalb steht jetzt auch im vordergrund
sehr entschlossenes handeln beim impfen
wir haben deshalb den krisenstab
eingerichtet und wollen jetzt wirklich
die große große aufgabe bewältigen das
sind ganz kurzer zeit ganz viele ihre
auffrischungsimpfung bekommen und sich
viele in diesem verlauf auch noch neue
impfen lassen also es wird hier
entschieden gehandelt und was mir
besonders wichtig ist einvernehmlich
denn das glaube ich haben die
bürgerinnen und bürger auch verdient das
nicht jeden tag irgendjemand sich zu
wort meldet und einen neuen vorschlag
macht sondern dass wir geordnet
miteinander diskutieren dann war diese
woche auch sehr gut und wie ich finde
auch beispielgebend wir hatten eine
vertrauliche diskussion der
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten ohne feste
tagesordnung und ohne die verpflichtung
sofort einen beschluss zu fassen sind
uns aber da so weitgehend einig geworden
dass wir jetzt auch das alles haben
finalisieren können das war ein guter
weg weil es geht ja ums zusammenführen
und ums führen dann kommt die letzte
frage von frau panzer von der ard
an herrn scholz und vielleicht wenn ich
darf auch nur zum abschied eine kurze
frage danach noch an frau merkel herr
scholz
großes thema in deutschland
fußballstadien da gab es ja schon die
situation zum beispiel in sachsen dass
man da so genannte geisterspiele
durchgeführt hat keine zuschauer
zugelassen hat bei ihnen in nordrhein
westfalen war es dann sehr sehr viele
jetzt hat man sich auf 15.000 geeinigt
es ist aber wieder so ein flickenteppich
für deutschland hätten sie sich da nicht
ein einheit für ganz deutschland
gewünscht dass eben in allen
fußballstadien in ganz deutschland die
gleichen regeln gelten und wirklich nur
die ganz kurze nachfrage an sie frau
bundeskanzlerin
warum haben sie sich für dieses lied du
hast den farbfilm vergessen heute
entschieden
sie beschreiben die situation die mich
wie wahrscheinlich fast alle bürgerinnen
und bürger
bewegt hat dass wir andererseits über
eine sehr schwierige lage
reden eine ganz ganz dramatische
situation auf den intensivstationen
unser krankenhäuser das überall
beschränkungen festgesetzt werden und
auch zweig für den handel jetzt zb ist
eine beschränkung die dazu führt dass es
anders läuft als sonst und gleichzeitig
gab es ganz voll besetzte fußballstadien
und deshalb war es richtig dass alle
jetzt sie sich auf ein gemeinsames
vorgehen festlegen und da haben wir
beschränken dass das ist jetzt hier
entschieden worden sondern in dem rahmen
gibt es natürlich unterschiedliche
situationen in unterschiedlichen ländern
und einige werden noch weitreichender
beschränkung ergreifen aber dass man
gesagt hat das kann nicht so bleiben wie
das jetzt ist da eine sehr drastische
entscheidung getroffen und das ist gut
das lied war ein highlight meiner jugend
die ja bekanntermaßen in der ddr
stattgefunden hat und das lied kam auch
aus der ddr und
zufälligerweise spielte dort noch in
einer region die mein früherer wahlkreis
war insofern passt alles zusammen
vielen dank einen schönen nachmittag
noch
am ende dann also doch noch mal ein
bisschen gute laune auf dieser
pressekonferenz wir sehen gerade noch
angela merkel und olaf scholz
miteinander scherzend aber der anlass
für diese pressekonferenz war natürlich
ein ernster und es wurde auch nicht
versäumt darauf hinzuweisen dass die
lage relativ ernst ist oder sehr ernst
sogar wir gucken noch mal auf die
wesentlichen aussagen die getroffen
worden sind also die bundeskanzlerin
sprach von einem akt der nationalen
solidarität die belastung an die
krankenhäuser sie komme jetzt eben doch
deutlich an die grenzen und deswegen
eben auch die strengen vorgaben und
maßnahmen die jetzt beschlossen worden
sind es wird auch festgehalten natürlich
an den 30 millionen impfungen
verabreicht werden sollen bis zum ende
des jahres nicht alles zusammen wir
sprechen gleich noch mit nicole diekmann
darüber aber auch olaf scholz hat noch
mal deutlich appelliert an die
ungeimpften sich jetzt nun doch bitte
bald impfen zu lassen die frage ist
natürlich ob das dann verfängt es gibt
bestimmt noch das ein oder andere zu
ergänzen nicole welches fazit sie isst
du nach dieser pressekonferenz
diese einheitlichkeit bzw die
einhelligkeit mit der man diese
beschlüsse heute gefasst hat ganz
wichtig einvernehmlich habe ich mir
aufgeschrieben das war ein stichwort auf
das hat olaf scholz der kommende
bundeskanzler großen wert gelegt und das
geht hand in hand mit dem was angela
merkel die scheidende bundeskanzlerin
deren letzte mpk wie es wahrscheinlich
heute stattgefunden hat auch noch gesagt
hat nämlich wir haben verstanden dass es
ernst ist es war wichtig es war ein
wichtig auf ihr politisches weiterkommen
weiterleben wichtig heute zu
demonstrieren wir beschließen
einheitlich
maßnahmen die zeigen wir wissen dass die
lage dramatisch ist und wir haben auch
verstanden dass die öffentlichkeit von
uns jetzt verlangt endlich was thun der
druck war ja da das ist das eine
inhaltlich harte marschroute würde ich
sagen zum einen zweig im einzelhandel
flächendeckend in ganz deutschland und
das ist wichtig inzidenz unabhängig es
wird jetzt im einzelhandel abgesehen von
geschäften für den täglichen bedarf
zweig eingeführt also weihnachtsshopping
nur noch für geld für geimpfte und für
genesene ein test reicht da nicht mehr
ungeimpfte können in solche läden nicht
mehr reingehen außerhalb von
supermärkten und drogerien
dasselbe gilt zweig wenn die inhaber das
möchten auch zweig plus führt zum
beispiel restaurants und für kino ist
dass das eine und das andere ist harte
kontakt beschränkungen und auch das
bezieht sich auf die ungeimpften trifft
sich ein haushalt mit einem anderen
haushalt und eine person dabei ist
ungeimpft das reicht schon dann sind nur
zudem einen haushalt zwei weitere
personen aus dem anderen haushalt
zugelassen noch mal sobald eine
ungeimpfte person dahinter ist da geht
es das geht eben in diesem fall für
ungeimpfte meine güte für geimpften und
verhört
da kommt ja man kommt hier wirklich
langsam durcheinander ich die leute
müssen es ja verstehen das tut mir leid
also ist eine person darunter bedeutet
dass kontakt beschränkungen ein haushalt
plus maximal zwei personen aus einem
weiteren haushalt kinder bis 14 jahren
sind davon aber ausgenommen sind wie
impfte personen
darunter gelten diese kontakt
beschränkung nicht da gelten dann
wiederum ab einer gewissen inzidenz die
inzidenz ist zurück das ist auch ein
signal das von heute ausginge da gibt es
ab einer inzidenz von 350 relativ hoch
aber es gibt ja etliche gegenden wo die
überschritten wird da gelten dann noch
mal andere beschränkungen für
veranstaltungen private veranstaltungen
im geschlossenen und im öffentlichen
raum nicole danke das war schon mal eine
sehr außer
gewöhnliche und vor allem
aussagekräftige umfangreiche
zusammenfassung dankeschön wir sprechen
hoffentlich gleich nochmal weiter ich
muss aber unsere runde noch einmal um
und will das auch gerne tun martin
stürmer erweitern denn er hat noch
verpflichtungen und steht uns noch zehn
minuten zur verfügung und deswegen ganz
kurz von ihnen gerne herr doktor stürmer
noch mal die einschätzung sind sie denn
mit dem was dort heute beschlossen
worden ist im großen und ganzen
zufrieden hat man den ernst der lage
erkannt
ja ich kann mich jetzt hier in dem
gerade gehörten nur anschließen das
haben sie ja vor zusammengefasst ich
habe da gar nicht so viel hinzuzufügen
es war von der symbolik glaube ich sehr
wichtig einheitlichkeit zu demonstrieren
auch für uns die wir das alter
kommunizieren und für die menschen die
es letztendlich auch begreifen und
umsetzen sollen ist das ganz ganz
wichtig dass wirklich mal wieder eine
einheitlichkeit herrscht dass die regeln
nachvollziehbar sind und überall gelten
sie gehen sehr weit auch geimpfte werden
teilweise in ihren freiheiten
beschnitten durch schließung von
diskotheken und clubs und so weiter also
man hat auch die risiken erkannt die
inzidenz ist das ist mir auch direkt
aufgefallen was ich sehr gut finde weil
das ist der wichtigste parameter der uns
früh zeigt wie das infektionsgeschehen
stattfindet also sehr viele schritte in
die richtige richtung wir müssen jetzt
halt einfach schauen wie sich das mit
omikron entwickelt ich hätte mir
tatsächlich präventiv gewünscht da noch
einen ticken härter mit den umkämpften
und gesten oder soll man mit den giften
so umzugehen also sprich da noch etwas
konsequenter zu sein weil er es noch
nicht wissen aber ich kann mit den
beschlüssen eigentlich sehr gut leben
weil vieles vieles richtig gemacht wird
wenn sie jetzt sagen noch härter damit
umgehen meinen sie kontakt
beschränkungen noch intensivieren habe
ich sie da wir verstehen ja auch jessica
watchers gefragt uns über youtube sie
können gleich weiter antworten die
inzidenz bei kindern und jugendlichen
ist riesig wird es zu vorgezogenen
weihnachtsferien kommen auch das wäre ja
sozusagen eine maßnahme um kontakte
weiter einzuschränken vielleicht können
sie das in ihrer antwort mit aufnehmen
ja meine meine vorteile meine idee war
ja das wäre im prinzip unabhängig vom
status geben es darum geht erst mal
komplett die kontakte reduzieren um die
konter besser zu verstehen und die
zahlen noch schneller runter zu bringen
aber wie gesagt ich kann mit den
vorschlägen auch sehr gut leben wenn sie
dann wirklich auch so umgesetzt werden
zeitnah ja was die schulen kindergärten
angeht da hatte ich ja schon gesagt dass
das meine letzte bastion wäre wo ich
dran rütteln werde und in wie weit
vorgezogene weihnachtsferien nicht jetzt
doch auch irgendwie wieder eine
belastung für die familiäre situation
darstellt ich denke eher dass wir da
sehr vorsichtig sein sollten und ob das
eine gute maßgabe ist weiß ich nicht
wichtig ist jetzt die fastentage pflicht
in den schulen wieder etablieren zu
etablieren damit sind wir gut gefahren
man muss schauen wie wir da jetzt die
zahlen runter kriegen also die masken
pflicht in den schulen ist ja wieder in
kraft auch das wurde ja vorgetragen
führen auf der pressekonferenz
dankeschön martin stürmer war das für
uns der virologe aus offenbach ich danke
ihnen ganz herzlich dass sie zur
verfügung gestanden haben und wir werden
uns mit sicherheit in den nächsten
wochen noch mal sprechen dankeschön wir
haben machen weiter mit nicole diekmann
in berlin oder vielleicht frage ich
gerade mal sagt acker die ja auch noch
bei uns im studio ist vielleicht mal zur
abwechslung was rechtlich ist wie
würdest du denn die beschlüsse jetzt
interpretieren diese gekommen sind hatte
ich irgendwas überrascht würdest du
sagen an der einen oder anderen stelle
könnte es vielleicht recht ich noch mal
heikel werden oder ernst wie interessant
das spannende finde ich dass die dinge
die klar beschlossen wurden also wie das
nur noch geimpfte und genesene in kinos
theater und restaurant gehen dürfen und
in geschäfte gehen dürfen wie die
kontakt beschränkungen die strengen für
ungeimpfte das sind alles dinge die auch
mit auf grundlage der des aktuellen
gesetzes
funktionieren was ich spannend fand das
in den beschluss hier einen punkt 14 zu
finden ist den ich aber in der
pressekonferenz öffentlich gehört habe
der irgendwie den niemand vorgetragen
habe ich hab es überhört und zwar das
nochmal ein auftrag an den gesetzgeber
gibt doch noch mal das
infektionsschutzgesetz zu ändern ich
weiß nicht ob sich keiner getraut hat
das auszusprechen ich nehme mal an es
gilt was hier festgehalten ist sogar von
google dass es da einen auftrag gibt
das ging ein bisschen auseinander also
das was hier steht und das was da gesagt
wurde
und da wird angesprochen dass man doch
oder die länder sich doch wünschen dass
es die möglichkeit geben soll
restaurants komplett zu schließen was
aktuell nicht möglich ist andere punkte
die hier zum beispiel einschränkungen
bei hotelübernachtungen
die sind aktuell möglich da ist mir
nicht ganz klar wie sie das hier mit
aufgenommen also man kann nicht hotels
komplett schließen aber natürlich kann
man auch zweig auch 2d plus regeln
anwenden also der gedanke an der
änderung des infektionsschutzgesetzes
war ja dass man durch die strengen
maßnahmen wie zweig zweige plus regeln
keine kompletten schließung mehr braucht
da bestehen wohl zweifel aber also ich
entnehme der pressekonferenz und diese
papier und auch in dem wie es hier
formuliert ist erwarte ich jetzt nicht
dass es sofort eine änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
gibt prüfauftrag ist ja auch was anderes
als ein klarer auftrag aber das ist ein
spannender rechtlicher punkt wo wir
einfach keine klarheit haben also
klarheit haben wir bei den dingen die
möglich sind und jetzt auch erhalten
bundeseinheitlich
verordnet werden sollen nicole diekmann
auch angesprochen hat das sind die
klaren zweig regeln und die kontakt
beschränkung und spannend fand ich auch
noch einen punkt ist mir aufgefallen in
der beschlussvorlage mai noch ein punkt
10 drin
weihnachtsmärkte auf man die nicht
komplett verbieten sollte oder da zweig
zweig plus da wurde hierzu in der
pressekonferenz gar nichts mehr gesagt
und in dem papier steht auch nichts drin
das heißt irgendwie an die
weihnachtsmärkte wollte man nicht kann
und ich fand auch auffällig dass die
ausführung zur großveranstaltung sehr
sparsam waren also das sind alles punkte
wo ich mir mehr klarheit gewünscht hätte
ehrlich gesagt und die mir die mieter
fehlt mir doch vielleicht gerade in der
politik noch mal mit in die runde die
uns dazu gehört hat also sarah tucker
vermisster ein bisschen die klarheit in
dem einen oder anderen punkt und sagt na
ja vielleicht wollte man das vielleicht
auch jetzt nicht so offensiv
kommunizieren könnte das sein hat man da
sorge vor der verkündung von unpopulären
maßnahmen das könnte eine möglichkeit
sein also die weihnachtsmärkte sind ja
aus dh die finden weiter statt auch das
ist unterschiedlich geregelt brandenburg
zum beispiel hier das nachbarland von
berlin hat die weihnachtsmärkte abgesagt
hier in berlin finden sie statt und zwar
die 2g regelung
ja ich teile sarahs eindruck den habe
ich auch gehabt dass man sich so ein
bisschen gemogelt hat um diese frage der
fußballstadion stadien
hendrik wüst der ministerpräsident von
nrw saß da ja auch gerade mit in der
runde und ein bild oder bilder aus
seinem bundesland vom vergangenen
wochenende wurden ja heute immer mal
wieder indirekt angesprochen und zwar
aus einem vollen fußballstadion mit ich
glaube 50.000 fans eine stunde vor
beginn des spiels war noch eigentlich
eine masken pflicht angeordnet worden an
die hat sich niemand gehalten da
sprechen die bilder eine eigene sprache
das wüster kein großes interesse daran
hat er das heute noch mal zu mit
thematisieren ist klar ganz eindeutig
hatte aber auch die ganze runde die der
heute zusammen gesessen hat wenig
interesse daran zu sagen ab jetzt ab
sofort bundesliga spiele ohne zuschauer
dazu konnte man sich nicht durchringen
diese option war noch in dieser
beschlussvorlage drin aber auch da schon
den eckigen klammern also ein hinweis
darauf da hatte man sich auch schon in
den verhandlungen vor der heutigen runde
nicht einigen können das heißt also das
war eine bittere pille die man den
leuten jetzt nicht verabreichen wollte
in einem punkt sarah muss ich dir
widersprechen das passiert mir auch
immer mal wieder dass man nicht alles
mitkriegt das ist eine wahnsinnig hohe
informationsdichte in diesen
pressekonferenzen es ist angesprochen
worden dass der gesetzgeber jetzt noch
einmal ans infektionsschutzgesetz dran
geht und man hat an einer stelle auch
das spielt ja in dieselbe richtung
vom regierenden
bürgermeister von berlin von müller doch
noch mal so ein bisschen partei gehacke
gehört als er nämlich noch mal darauf
hinwies also es sei in diesem neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz beziehungsweise
in den änderungen der die ampel da sitzt
auch seine spd ja mit drin auf den weg
gebracht worden sei seien weitreichende
maßnahmen gewesen also die beendigung
beziehungsweise das auslaufen lassen die
nichtverlängerung der epidemischen lage
von nationaler tragweite das sei viel
umstrittener als nötig da sieht man also
nochmal da spricht eben auch der partei
man genauso wie hendrik wüst der cdu
mann derjenige war der sich noch mal bei
angela merkel ebenfalls cdu wie wir
wissen bedankt hat also so ganz lassen
können sie es nicht aber auch eine
wichtige information die wir vielleicht
nochmal einmal an bringen sollen ist gab
ja diese übergangsfrist bis mitte
dezember nach dem auslaufen der
epidemischen lage die soll ja jetzt auch
noch einmal verlängert werden das ist
eben auch noch mal angesprochen worden
aber unterm strich ich könnte mir
ehrlich gesagt auch vorstellen
sara sagt ja auch es ist unglaublich
unübersichtlich geworden in diesem
papier steht ja auch übrigens wir
beschließen dass das war aber auch
bisher schon möglich vielleicht hat man
auch schlicht und einfach den überblick
verloren weil 12 punkten und zum anderen
will aber noch mal deutlich machen was
da aus den ländern kommt ist zum teil
auch der versuch einfach verantwortung
von sich wegzuschieben und auf den hund
zu zeigen ja einerseits tröstlich dass
da offenbar auch ab und zu der überblick
von konkret
wünscht man sich natürlich aus der
politik genau das gerade nicht sarah
wolltest du nochmal darauf ja es wurde
angesprochen dass es ein gesetz
gesetzesänderung geben könnte sollte das
das geprüft wird aber in welchen
konkreten punkten geht weder aus der
beschlussvorlage noch aus der
pressekonferenz vor also was soll da wie
so geändert werden dass ist völlig offen
das wurde auch nicht also vielleicht hab
ich auch das über hat aber das wurde
meines wissens nicht angespannt geht
hier hier sind so ein paar vorschläge
gemacht die sehr diffus sind die auch in
ihrer aufzählung keinen sinn machen und
also da gibt es also in meiner
interpretation weiterhin unklarheit +
finde ich erstaunlich dass man bei
weihnachtsmärkten großveranstaltung also
zwei ja auch
kontakt orte die aktuell diskutiert
werden dass man da nicht für
bundeseinheitliche regelung gesorgt hat
man hätte ja auch hier vereinbarungen
treffen können die klarheit schaffen das
hat man bewusst nicht gemacht und das
sind ja in der tat gerade heikle punkte
und unter hätte klarheit gut an so wie
man sie beim einzelhandel und in
restaurants und in theatern geschaffen
klarheit und einheitlichkeit war ja
eigentlich auch das erklärte ziel dieser
ganzen veranstaltung offenbar hat man
das nicht in allen punkten so
durchhalten können oder wollen kritik
von deiner seite also auch von noah die
tristen über youtube er schreibt die
maßnahmen sind sehr milde ich hoffe dass
die bundesländer weitere maßnahmen
beschließen das vielleicht auch noch mal
zum hintergrund also punkt 15 der
vorlage hier sieht vor dass die
vorgenannten maßnahmen markieren also
bundesweit einheitliche mindeststandards
und damit können die länder auch darüber
hinaus gehen wenn die entsprechenden
lager verorten also verlagen vor ort ist
erfordern wenn die instanzen
entsprechend hoch sind dann können sie
über diese standards hinausgehen
vielleicht nochmal nicole auch an dicht
die frage also man muss sagen michael
müller hat es angesprochen der
regierende bürgermeister in berlin eine
deutliche minderheit der bevölkerung
sollte erst ausgedrückt ist für eine
deutliche mehrheit der infektion
verantwortlich daher müsse jetzt langsam
der unterschied in der behandlung dieser
menschen auch deutlich werden ist das
sozusagen mit dem ergebnis heute
geschehen oder wird das jetzt in den
nächsten wochen vor allem auch zu spüren
sein ja natürlich also dass ich als
ungeimpfte nicht mehr ins restaurant
gehen kann nicht mehr ins kino nicht
mehr ins theater das sich auch nicht
mehr in eine rot ihr gehen kann und mir
was zum anziehen kaufen oder in ein
spielzeugladen um die
weihnachtsgeschenke zu kaufen
das schränkt ein natürlich immens ein
und müller ist immer wieder in diesen
pressekonferenzen derjenige gewesen der
einen anderen ton angeschlagen hat als
die anderen in der runde also weniger
lokal sondern tatsächlich er die einen
sagen dies kritisieren wie ein vater wie
ein schulmeister die anderen sagen
angemessen daran an die tatsache dass es
tatsächlich eine minderheit ist die
gerade dafür verantwortlich ist was hier
los ist auf jeden fall die schärfere
tonart und er macht eben kein geheimnis
daraus dass diese maßnahmen jetzt
beschlossen worden sind auch mit dem
impetus den druck zu erhöhen sich impfen
zu lassen das hat er vor ein paar
monaten schon mal gemacht wir erinnern
uns die kostenlose bürger tests wurden
abgeschafft und da war auch müller
derjenige der auf der anschließenden
pressekonferenz gesagt hat so und
dadurch dass sich leute jetzt nicht mehr
auf kosten der allgemeinheit testen
lassen können also auch keine tests mehr
vorweisen können um gewisse privilegien
in anspruch zu nehmen wird jetzt der
druck erhöht werden dass die sich impfen
dabei außer deutlich wie wir wissen ist
diese rechnung nicht aufgegangen die
kostenlosen bürger test sind zurück ist
aber eine andere geschichte also müller
ist da immer sehr deutlich in seiner
ansprache und wie wir sehen konnten auch
sehr ungeduldig und relativ hohe
verständnis für diejenigen die sich
impfen lassen könnten und ist trotzdem
nicht tun vielleicht nicole zum schluss
noch mal ein wort zur noch kanzlerin
hendrik wüst der ministerpräsident nrw
er sagte ja und er lobt noch mal
besonders tat hervor die verdienste von
angela merkel in den vergangenen 16
jahren und man hatte so ein bisschen den
eindruck ist war ja fast etwas
unangenehm sie ist ja sowieso jetzt
keine person die so besonders gerne
irgendwie jetzt das rampenlicht sucht so
hat man manchmal den eindruck oder so
positiv im mittelpunkt stehen möchte wie
war dein eindruck von dieser situation
es gab eine geste die sie gemacht hat
während hendrik wüst sprach und das hat
strich sich ihre haare hinters ohr das
macht sie selten das habe ich also eine
übersprungshandlung bewertet dass sie
tatsächlich nicht so genau wusste wohin
mit sich in diesem also wie soll sie
darauf reagieren sie kann sich nicht
freudestrahlend dafür bedanken denn wir
stecken mitten in der vierten welle die
ist massiver als jede zu force ist eine
dramatische lage nicht umsonst ist man
heute zusammengekommen nicht umsonst
sagt man da ja eben in dieser runde und
hat die beschlüsse verkündet die ja
relativ weit reichend sind deswegen also
ich habe mir das mit angeguckt und
dachte auch was solche haben wir frau
jetzt zu machen das ist natürlich sehr
freundlich von hendrik wüst das gehört
sich auch so vor allem wenn man auch
gehört ja auch so war dazu in derselben
partei ist aber wie gesagt also
auf den tisch zu gucken die augen
niedergeschlagen so ein bisschen demütig
diesen dank anzunehmen und dann auch die
gelegenheit tapfer oder dankbar zu
ergreifen in dem moment in dem hendrik
wüst auf ihren höchst wahrscheinlicher
nachfolger olaf scholz zu sprechen kam
zu ihm zu gucken und ihn an zu lächeln
ich glaube das war die einzige reaktion
die sie für angemessen gehalten hat und
die auch tatsächlich angemessen war es
ist kein grund zum jubeln nein das kann
man wohl wahrlich nicht sagen dafür ist
die situation nach wie vor zu ernst aber
da hat sie doch finde ich auch eine gute
figur gemacht vielen dank eine gute
figur hast auch du gemacht nicole
dankeschön für dieses gespräch hier mit
uns wir sind sehr froh dass wir das
ganze mit dir so ausführlich noch mal
diskutieren konnten auch im vorfeld ja
schon danke nach berlin danke auch an
sagen die natürlich ebenfalls eine tolle
figur gemacht hat möchtest du noch einen
satz vielleicht abschließend loswerden
was kommt da jetzt in den nächsten
wochen auf uns zu bis so mit dem
erreichten heute einverstanden du hast
wenn ja schon deine kritik ein bisschen
anbringen können aber hast du noch in
gedanken durch den kopf geht
es ist gut dass klarheit geschaffen
wurde dass die länder sich wirklich
darauf verständigen konnten
in allen bundesländern
die 2g regeln für theater restaurants
und den einzelhandel einzuführen wie
auch andere kontakte beschränken also da
gibt es klarheit und einheit und das ist
gut
gleichzeitig finde ich haben sich einen
schlanken fuß gemacht wenn es um
großveranstaltungen und weihnachtsmärkte
geht und ärgerlich finde ich auch dass
es keine klarheit gibt was da jetzt
gesetzgeberisch noch mal geändert und
werden soll und ich finde es ein
bisschen erstaunlich weil was in der
beschlussvorlage steht das einzige von
dem was dazu muss aufgeführt es ist das
aktuell ist nicht möglich ist
restaurants zu schließen ich weiß nicht
ob das jetzt der grund ist machen wir
dieses gesetz anzufassen am ende ist man
ja froh wenn überhaupt noch jemand damit
kommt und versteht was aktuelle lage ist
und vielleicht reicht es auch strenge
zweig plus regeln in restaurants zu
machen und dann muss man nicht noch eine
gesetzesänderung machen also ich bin was
die gesetzesänderung noch mal anbelangt
skeptisch ob die notwendig ist aber der
wurde heute auch einfach nichts detail
jedes zugesagt also es ging in die
richtige richtung es ist einiges auf den
weg gebracht worden aber wir werden
natürlich das ganze in den nächsten
wochen weiter begleiten müssen und
gucken okay was konkret folgt jetzt da
raus und wie entwickeln sich die dinge
weiter reicht das aus was jetzt eben
dort verabschiedet worden ist
beziehungsweise was jetzt eben dann auch
bald kommen wird dankeschön sarah auch
noch mal an dich für deine
einschätzungen danke natürlich auch noch
mal an unsere userinnen und user das war
ein langer livestream aber ich denke es
hat sich gelohnt wir haben einiges
erfahren aus bedienen konnten das
einordnen dank an euch einen schönen tag
und bis zum nächsten